This episode is supported by Anthropic, the team behind Claude. Now, history's biggest leaps started as hard questions that people didn't want asked. Yeah, there's a classic example of that at the end of the 15th century. And the hard question in particular was, what is out there beyond the Atlantic Ocean to the west? And as you will know, the man who found the answer to that question was the explorer Christopher Columbus. And he realizes, or rather everybody else realizes, that there is a vast continent out there. And it is, of course, the Americas. So Anthropic knows the importance of questions. And it's why Anthropic is founded on one hard question above all. How can we ensure that the AI revolution
本集由Claude背后的团队Anthropic赞助。历史上最伟大的飞跃，往往始于人们不愿触及的难题。在15世纪末，就有一个经典的例子。当时那个棘手的难题是：大西洋以西究竟有什么？正如你们所知，找到这个答案的人是探险家克里斯托弗·哥伦布。他意识到，或者说其他人意识到，那里有一片广阔的大陆。当然，那就是美洲。Anthropic深知提问的重要性。这也是Anthropic创立时最核心的一个难题：我们如何确保人工智能革命
really goes well for ordinary people? So they asked over 100,000 people and what came back wasn't just fear. There was hope as well. People wanted to know, will cancer ever be cured? It turns out that there is hope in hard questions. Ask yours at clodd.aI slash rest is history. And keep thinking. A commotion at the doorway brought me back to life, trying to start up and failing thanks to the weight of those infernal clanking manacles. As the door crashed shut again, I was aware of a swaying figure in the middle of the room,
能真正造福普通人？于是他们询问了超过10万人的意见，得到的反馈不仅有恐惧，还有希望。人们想知道，癌症终有一天会被治愈吗？事实证明，难题中蕴含着希望。请访问clodd.aI/rest is history提出你的问题。并保持思考。门口的一阵骚动让我回过神来，我试图起身，却因为那些该死的沉重镣铐而失败了。当门再次砰地关上时，我注意到房间中央有一个摇晃的身影，
bare to the waist. How are you? How are you, my dear friend, my best friend, cries this apparition. whooping with laughter. Thank God, I am well. Are you well? Ah, my good friend, my heart rejoices to see you for the friendship I have entertained for you as not diminished.
赤裸着上身。“你好吗？你好吗，我亲爱的朋友，我最好的朋友，”这个幻影大喊道，并发出欢快的笑声。“感谢上帝，我很好。你还好吗？啊，我的好朋友，见到你我心中欢喜，因为我对你的友谊从未减退。”
Be of good cheer. For though you are bound with fetters of Samson and Zetakaya were bound even with fetters of brass, yet, yet. his voice trailed away muttering And who else Yeah, Yer Kim also was bound And Manessa They were bound by the power of God And so was Goseim
“振作起来。因为虽然你被束缚，就像参孙和西底家被铜链锁住一样，但是，但是……”他的声音渐渐低沉，嘟囔着，“还有谁？是的，约雅斤也被囚禁了。还有玛拿西。他们被上帝的力量所束缚。歌珊也是如此。”
Who was sold for a servant Whose feet they hurt with fetters And he was laid in iron And then he gave another crazy laugh And almost fell over But have no fear, for the hour of your deliverance is at hand. My eyes had recovered from the lamp glare, but I could hardly believe them. For the newcomer was Theodore, king of Abyssinia, and he was staggeringly drunk.
“他被卖为奴隶，他的脚被镣铐所伤，他被置于铁链之中。”然后他又发出一阵疯狂的笑声，差点摔倒。“但不要害怕，因为你获救的时刻即将来临。”我的眼睛已经适应了灯光，但我几乎不敢相信所见的一切。因为来人正是阿比西尼亚国王西奥多，而且他醉得不省人事。
That was the great Victorian hero, Sir Harry Flashman, remembering his first meeting with the Emperor Teodros II in his memoir Flashman on the march. it is to reiterate a novel, not a work of history, but it is very, very deeply rooted in all the historical records. And in the book, Flashman has been sent on a secret mission to recruit allies against the Abyssinian Emperor, Teodros II, as part of a British expedition to rescue several dozen European hostages. And even though Flashman's part of it, as we've said, is inventing. all the most jaw-dropping parts of the story in the novel, Theodorus, his mountain lair, the British expedition are absolutely true. And today we have reached the melodramatic climax of the story. And Dominic, this is ultimately, it's a British imperial version of the Iranian hostage crisis, isn't it? Yes.
那是伟大的维多利亚时代英雄，哈里·弗莱什曼爵士，在他的回忆录《弗莱什曼在进军途中》中回忆他与提奥多罗斯二世皇帝的第一次会面。这毕竟是一部小说，而非历史著作，但它深深植根于所有的历史记录之中。在书中，弗莱什曼被派去执行一项秘密任务，作为英国远征军的一部分，去招募盟友对抗阿比西尼亚皇帝提奥多罗斯二世，以营救几十名欧洲人质。尽管正如我们所说，弗莱什曼参与的部分是虚构的，但故事中所有令人瞠目结舌的部分——提奥多罗斯、他的山中巢穴、英国的远征——都是绝对真实的。今天，我们已经到达了这个故事的戏剧性高潮。多米尼克，这归根结底是伊朗人质危机的英国帝国版本，对吧？是的。
And if only Jimmy Carter had paid attention to the lesson that could. have been learnt from our glorious boys in 1868 the way that they solved the problem of hostages in the hands of an unfriendly regime. So true, Tom. I'm not sure his knowledge of Victorian imperial history is as good as it should be. I mean, one of the flaws, he spent too much time fighting rabbits. The key, as far as I can tell, is to involve railways and elephants. Elephants.
如果吉米·卡特能注意到1868年我们光荣的士兵所留下的教训，即他们解决敌对政权手中人质问题的方式，那该多好。确实如此，汤姆。我不确定他对维多利亚时代帝国历史的了解是否足够深入。我的意思是，他的一大缺陷是花了太多时间去打兔子。据我所知，关键在于动用铁路和大象。大象。
Which may be where Carter went wrong. Definitely. So let's remind people where and when we are, summer of 1867. So for four years or so, this crisis has been rumbling on in the Mountain Kingdom of Abyssinia. And at the root is the Emperor Teodros' simmering rage at the fact that Queen Victoria has not been answering his letters. And he has taken a group of Europeans hostage, so most of the missionaries, but also to remind people the British Consul, Captain Charles Duncan Cameron, and the foreign office is agent Hormuz Rassam, and he's holding them in his mountaintop lair, his citadel of Magdalas. And the hostages have been smuggling out these increasingly desperate messages, a reporting that Teodros is descending into insanity and basically begging the foreign office to use force. And last time he ended with Lord Darby's Conservative government sending an ultimatum to Abyssinia, giving Teodros three months to release them. So let's pick up the story on the 19th of August in London.
这可能就是卡特出错的地方。绝对是。那么，让我们提醒大家我们身处何时何地：1867年夏天。这场危机在阿比西尼亚的山地王国已经酝酿了四年左右。根源在于提奥多罗斯皇帝对维多利亚女王没有回复他的信件而产生的满腔怒火。他扣押了一群欧洲人作为人质，主要是传教士，但也包括英国领事查尔斯·邓肯·卡梅伦上尉和外交部特工霍尔穆兹·拉萨姆。他把他们关在山顶的巢穴——马格达拉城堡里。人质们一直在偷偷传出这些日益绝望的信息，报告说提奥多罗斯正陷入疯狂，并恳求外交部动用武力。上次我们讲到德比勋爵的保守党政府向阿比西尼亚发出了最后通牒，给提奥多罗斯三个月的时间释放他们。那么，让我们从8月19日的伦敦开始继续讲述。
We are at 10 Downing Street, and chairing the cabinet is Lord Derby. And Lord Darby is a proper Victorian grandee, formerly a wig, now a conservative, incredibly rich. He has coal mines in Lancashire. He is classically educated. He's a brilliant debater. He's a man who likes shooting and horse racing. He's sort of Victorian politics bingo, and he runs the country in cahoots with his sort of ally in the commons, Benjamin Disraeli. He was the
我们现在在唐宁街10号，主持内阁会议的是德比勋爵。德比勋爵是一位典型的维多利亚时代显贵，曾是辉格党人，现在是保守党人，极其富有。他在兰开夏郡拥有煤矿。他受过古典教育。他是一位出色的辩论家。他是一个喜欢射击和赛马的人。他简直就是维多利亚时代政治的缩影，他与他在下议院的盟友本杰明·迪斯雷利勾结在一起管理国家。他是
longest serving conservative political leader ever. 22 years. He was prime minister multiple times, but only for very short spells. And he never had a majority. No. And he relied, I mean, he's in the lords and he relied on Disraeli to run things in the commons. Anyway, they meet
历史上任职时间最长的保守党政治领袖。22年。他多次担任首相，但每次任期都很短。而且他从未获得过多数席位。是的。他依靠——我的意思是，他在上议院，他依靠迪斯雷利来处理下议院的事情。总之，他们召开了
his cabinet and they agree this cannot stand. As British governments always do, they blame their predecessors, the liberals, and they say the liberals should have sorted this out. However, they didn't, and here we are. And we are being embarrassed in the eyes of the world. In particular, we're being embarrassed in the eyes of our subjects in India and in South Arabian places like Aden.
内阁会议，一致认为这种情况不能再持续下去了。正如英国政府一贯的做法，他们指责前任自由党人，说自由党人本应解决这个问题。然而，他们没有解决，所以我们现在陷入了这种境地。我们在世界面前感到尴尬。特别是，我们在印度的臣民和像亚丁这样的南阿拉伯地区面前感到尴尬。
And we cannot lose face in front of these people. We cannot be humiliated by an African king. So, Lord Darby's ministers have already been in touch with officials in Bombay to discuss an intervention plan. The army in India has been put on alert, and they've agreed that the British authorities in India will meet all the costs an important point, although they do, as Flashman and his interlocutor were discussing in our first episode,
我们不能在这些人面前丢脸。我们不能被一个非洲国王羞辱。所以，德比勋爵的部长们已经与孟买的官员取得了联系，讨论干预计划。印度的军队已经进入戒备状态，他们同意英国在印度的当局将承担所有费用——这是一个重要的点，尽管正如弗莱什曼和他的对话者在我们第一集中讨论的那样，
they do end up putting a penny on income tax to pay for it all. British governments love for raising spending to fund defence, don't they? They do. Well, there's a lesson here for Andy Burnham, I think. Anyway, they've also appointed a guy who will run the expedition.
他们最终还是在所得税上加了一便士来支付这一切。英国政府喜欢增加开支来资助国防，不是吗？确实。嗯，我想这对安迪·伯纳姆来说是个教训。总之，他们还任命了一个将负责这次远征的人。
And this is the veteran British commander-in-chief in Bombay, who is Lieutenant General Sir Robert Napier, of the Royal Engineers. He's a tremendous man. Napier is a tremendous man, actually. He's one of the stars of the British Army, and he's one of those in an age when British commanders actually quite often turn out to be unbelievably useless,
这就是孟买的资深英国总司令，皇家工程兵部队的罗伯特·纳皮尔中将。他是一个了不起的人。纳皮尔确实是一个了不起的人。他是英国军队中的明星之一，而且在那个英国指挥官往往被证明是极其无能、
buffoons. He is not a buffoon. He's not a buffoon at all. He was born in Ceylon, now Sri Lanka, into an army family. He'd fought in two wars against the Sikhs. He'd commanded the defence of Lucknow in the Indian mutiny. He'd led troops into Beijing.
愚蠢的时代，他不是一个笨蛋。他根本不是笨蛋。他出生在锡兰（现在的斯里兰卡）的一个军人家庭。他参加过两次对锡克教徒的战争。他在印度民族大起义中指挥过勒克瑙的防御战。他曾率军进入北京，
in the Second Opium War. He's incredibly popular with his men. Everyone agrees that Napier is a charming, polite, brave, level-headed, very methodical commander who doesn't like wasting the lives of his men. He looks as he should. He's a big man. He's got this incredibly kind of weather-beaten face. And he's got this very large but also slightly sad, melancholy moustache, which again, I think, is in keeping.
参加第二次鸦片战争。他在士兵中极受欢迎。大家都认为纳皮尔是一位迷人、礼貌、勇敢、头脑冷静、非常有条理的指挥官，他不愿浪费士兵的生命。他看起来就该是那个样子。他是个大块头。他有一张饱经风霜的脸。他留着非常浓密但又略带忧郁的胡子，我认为这也很符合他的形象。
But not an ineffectual man, because he's an engineer, isn't he? Yes, exactly. He gets things done. He gets things built. He doesn't faff around. Yeah. And that's key to this whole story, really, I guess. Our American listeners will perhaps welcome a comparison with Ulysses S. Grant,
但他不是一个无能的人，因为他是一名工程师，对吧？是的，完全正确。他能把事情办成。他能把事情建起来。他不瞎折腾。是的。我想这确实是整个故事的关键。我们的美国听众或许会欢迎将他与尤利西斯·S·格兰特进行比较，
who's been distinguishing himself at this time. Though he's not as corrupt as Ulysses S. Grant. Not, of course. And not as boring. So I think American listeners always enjoy it when we make those points. He's 57. His wife, his beloved wife, to whom he's been very happily married, has just died. And so Napier has ventured again into the lists.
他在那个时期也表现出色。虽然他不像尤利西斯·S·格兰特那样腐败。当然不是。也不像他那么无聊。所以我认为美国听众总是喜欢我们提出这些观点。他57岁了。他深爱的妻子，与他婚姻非常幸福的妻子，刚刚去世。所以纳皮尔再次踏上了征程。
And he's just got married to an 18-year-old. Well, I don't know what to say about that. What do you make of that? Well, I'm waiting for you to say the salient fact about this woman. What is the salient fact? She's from Montgomeryshire. She's Welsh. Oh, my word.
他刚刚娶了一位18岁的妻子。嗯，我不知道该对此说些什么。你对此有何看法？嗯，我在等你说出关于这个女人的一个显著事实。什么显著事实？她是蒙哥马利郡人。她是威尔士人。天哪。
How did I overlook that? So yet another series about Welsh history. Oh, mad that I missed that. My apologies go to the people to Wales for missing it in importance detail. Yeah, you're just blanking Welsh history again, Dominic. And can I tell you one other amazing thing? Do you know when she died? 1944.
我怎么会忽略这一点？所以这又是关于威尔士历史的系列节目。哦，我竟然错过了这一点，真是太疯狂了。我向威尔士人民道歉，因为我忽略了这个重要的细节。是的，多米尼克，你又在无视威尔士历史了。我还能告诉你一件令人惊奇的事吗？你知道她是什么时候去世的吗？1944年。
Very close, 1930. Wow. Aged 89. That's bonkers, isn't it? She lived so long. It is, isn't it? She lived long enough to listen to jazz and to go to the cinema to see King Kong. She lived a long time.
非常接近，1930年。哇。享年89岁。这太疯狂了，不是吗？她活了那么久。确实，不是吗？她活得足够长，可以听爵士乐，去电影院看《金刚》。她活了很长时间。
She saw the jazz singer. She did. That's what killed her. Yeah. All right. So, Napier. This is quite a tough gig for Napier. Now, you may think are the Europeans against an African kingdom a little bit of
她看了《爵士歌手》。她看了。那就是害死她的原因。是的。好吧。那么，纳皮尔。这对纳皮尔来说是一项相当艰巨的任务。现在，你可能认为欧洲人对抗一个非洲王国是不是有点
a walkover, not a bit of it. The history of European intervention in these years does not give great grounds for confidence. So the most famous or infamous British intervention of recent years was probably the Afghanistan, the first Anglo-Afghan War. The retreat from Kabul in 1842, an absolute shambles. tens of thousands of British casualties, an utter humiliation. Flashman's first adventure.
轻而易举，一点也不。这些年来欧洲干预的历史并没有给人带来多大的信心。所以近年来最著名或臭名昭著的英国干预可能是阿富汗，第一次英阿战争。1842年从喀布尔撤退，简直是一场灾难。数以万计的英国伤亡，彻底的羞辱。弗莱什曼的第一次冒险。
Flashman's first adventure. Flashman then pitched up in the Crimea in the mid-1850s. Now, there, of course, technically won, but the British and French between them lost more than 100,000 men. The campaign was notorious for disease, terrible conditions, kind of industrial slaughter, very miserable. And we will be talking about this in a month or so. We will indeed.
弗莱什曼的第一次冒险。弗莱什曼随后在19世纪50年代中期出现在克里米亚。在那里，当然，技术上赢了，但英法联军总共损失了超过10万名士兵。那场战役以疾病、恶劣的条件、工业化的屠杀而闻名，非常悲惨。我们会在一个月左右的时间里谈论这个。我们确实会。
While this Abyssinian crisis has been brewing, the world's attention has been on Mexico, where the French had intervened with their puppet emperor Maximilian Hapsburg, friend of the show, and the French had lost almost 10,000 men, and again they had been defeated. So European interventions in this period have a pretty checkered record, and people say at the time this is going to be the hardest yet. The Abyssinian interior is not properly mapped. It's mountains, it's gorges, it could not be. be more challenging. Intel is absolutely useless. The climate is punishingly hot. There's cholera,
当这场阿比西尼亚危机正在酝酿时，世界的注意力集中在墨西哥，法国人干预了那里，扶持了他们的傀儡皇帝马克西米连·哈布斯堡（本节目的朋友），法国人损失了近1万名士兵，而且他们再次被击败。所以这一时期的欧洲干预记录相当糟糕，当时人们说这将是最艰难的一次。阿比西尼亚的内陆地区没有经过适当的测绘。那里有山脉、峡谷，不可能
there's typhoid, there's lions, there's snakes. Baboons. Everything could go wrong. In Bombay, Napier's officers prepare by going to every library in Bombay and scouring every single history and travel book they can find for references to Abyssinia. And then they write a report. And the report concludes, there are few countries about which we know less. That's reassuring. So to give you some examples of what they don't know, they don't really know where Teodros is. They don't know how much support he has. They don't have any relations whatsoever with the local warlords, the people who are rebelling against him. They don't have any sense of which way they would jump.
更具挑战性了。情报完全没用。气候炎热得令人难以忍受。有霍乱，有伤寒，有狮子，有蛇。狒狒。一切都可能出错。在孟买，纳皮尔的军官们通过去孟买的每一家图书馆，搜寻他们能找到的每一本历史和旅行书籍，寻找关于阿比西尼亚的参考资料来做准备。然后他们写了一份报告。报告的结论是：我们所知甚少的国家寥寥无几。这真让人放心。所以举几个他们不知道的例子：他们真的不知道提奥多罗斯在哪里。他们不知道他有多少支持。他们与当地军阀（那些反抗他的人）没有任何关系。他们根本不知道这些人会倒向哪一边。
They don't know where to land. They don't know what route to take to Magdalar. And they don't know how they're going to get out again without being attacked. But as you said, Napier is an engineer. Yeah. So he is the perfect man for the job, really. He plans this really methodically. And he says, right, let's work backwards.
他们不知道在哪里登陆。他们不知道去马格达拉走哪条路线。他们不知道如何在不被攻击的情况下撤出来。但正如你所说，纳皮尔是一名工程师。是的。所以他确实是这项工作的完美人选。他非常有条理地计划了这一切。他说，好吧，让我们倒推一下。
what we would need, we'd need 5,000 men to get these people out. And what would those 5,000 men need? They would need supply lines stretching back to the coast, stretching for hundreds of miles. So we'll need another 10,000 men to guard the supply lines. Then we need a coastal base. And we ideally want two connections, one going up the Red Sea to Suez and another going across the Indian Ocean to Bombay.
我们需要什么？我们需要5000人把这些人救出来。这5000人需要什么？他们需要延伸到海岸的补给线，延伸数百英里。所以我们需要另外1万名士兵来保卫补给线。然后我们需要一个沿海基地。我们理想中需要两条连接线，一条沿着红海到苏伊士，另一条穿过印度洋到孟买。
And to plan all this, we're going to draw on the resources of the entire British. Empire, says Philip Marsden says in his book, the Barefoot Emperor. From Liverpool to Woolwich, Chatham to Bombay. Chatham. That was a little gift to you. Oh, great. So this is really another story about Chatham High Street. Aidan to Madras, quartermasters and storekeepers, technicians and chemists, coolies and cooks, design clerks, bookkeepers and stevedores began to work towards freeing the captives from the grip of what the newspapers called the Gorilla King. And they go into incredible detail. Marsden's book is brilliant on this. They work out, you know, to the sort of last pound exactly how much salt beef, salt pork, they'll need how much vinegar and mustard,
为了计划这一切，我们将利用整个大英帝国的资源，菲利普·马斯登在他的书《赤脚皇帝》中这样写道。从利物浦到伍尔维奇，从查塔姆到孟买。查塔姆。那是给你的一点小礼物。哦，太棒了。所以这确实是另一个关于查塔姆大街的故事。从亚丁到马德拉斯，军需官和仓库管理员、技术人员和化学家、苦力和厨师、设计文员、簿记员和装卸工开始努力工作，从报纸所称的“大猩猩国王”手中解救俘虏。他们进入了令人难以置信的细节。马斯登的书在这方面非常出色。他们计算出，精确到最后一磅，他们需要多少咸牛肉、咸猪肉，需要多少醋和芥末，
how much rum and champagne and beer. Champagne. They take champagne with them. That's essential, isn't it? Of course they do. You can't fight a war in Abyssinia without plentiful supplies of champagne. They stockpile Bibles and prayer books and pickaxes and gunpowder and, and One of the things they stop, are very tellingly, copper, telegraph, wire. So this is going to be, it's described at the time
多少朗姆酒、香槟和啤酒。香槟。他们随身带着香槟。这很关键，不是吗？当然。在阿比西尼亚打仗没有充足的香槟供应是不行的。他们储备了圣经、祈祷书、镐和火药，而且，他们储备的一样东西非常能说明问题：铜电报线。所以这将被描述为当时
as a campaign to rival the Adventures of Alexander the Great or Erlan Cortez or Pizarro or whatever. But this is going to be the most technologically advanced military campaign in history. So Napier is taking seven photographers. He's taking a portable telegraph system.
一场足以媲美亚历山大大帝、埃尔南·科尔特斯或皮萨罗等人的冒险的战役。但这将是历史上技术最先进的军事行动。所以纳皮尔带了七名摄影师。他带了一套便携式电报系统。
He's taking all kinds of water pumps and things. He's taking flares to light up the camp in case they're attacked at night. So it's kind of the great exhibition on manoeuvres. Yeah, the touring great exhibition. Like Napoleon in Egypt, he's taking, Napoleon called them Savants, the French campaign. So he's got geographers and meteorologists. He's got a boat from the Bombay Zoological Society.
他带了各种水泵之类的东西。他带了照明弹，以防他们在夜间受到攻击。所以这就像是演习中的大博览会。是的，巡回大博览会。就像拿破仑在埃及一样，他带了——拿破仑称他们为“学者”，法国的战役。所以他有地理学家和气象学家。他有来自孟买动物学会的一条船。
He's got a geologist from Calcutta. He's got a British Museum archaeologist who's coming along to kind of check for relics, and the press are with them. So we mentioned in the first episode, Henry Morton Stanley of the New York Herald, G.A. Henty of the Standard, which is a London paper. So they've got all that. They also are going to take a lot of cash. And this is an incredible story. They will need cash to buy supplies when they get to Abyssinia and also to pay off the local warlords. And British agents in Africa report, they say, well, that neck of the woods in East Africa. There's only one commonly accepted universal currency. And this is, believe it or not,
他有来自加尔各答的地质学家。他有一位大英博物馆的考古学家随行，负责检查文物，新闻界也与他们同行。所以我们在第一集中提到了《纽约先驱报》的亨利·莫顿·斯坦利，《标准报》（伦敦的一份报纸）的G.A.亨蒂。所以他们拥有所有这些。他们还将带上大量的现金。这是一个不可思议的故事。他们需要现金在到达阿比西尼亚时购买补给，并收买当地军阀。非洲的英国特工报告说，他们说，嗯，在东非的那片地区。只有一种普遍接受的通用货币。这就是，信不信由你，
the Austrian silver tala, which was minted first by Maria Teresa in 1741. How come it's so popular in Abyssinia? This, I have been unable to determine. Seems improbable. So apparently the silver tala that they wanted most was the 1780 edition. I don't know why. But this was the one that was regarded as the, I was about to say the gold standard, the silver standard, that was very popular in East Africa. And mind-bogglingly, people were still using this as currency in the 1950s. Goodness. These Maria Theresa silver coins. And for some reason, they have just become entrenched and accepted in East Africa. But they're no longer making them in Vienna. And Napier's agents, first of all, Napier sends agents to Central Europe to buy up as
奥地利银塔勒，最初由玛丽亚·特蕾莎于1741年铸造。为什么它在阿比西尼亚这么受欢迎？这一点我无法确定。似乎不太可能。所以显然他们最想要的银塔勒是1780年版的。我不知道为什么。但这被认为是——我正要说是金本位，银本位，这在东非非常流行。令人难以置信的是，人们在20世纪50年代还在使用它作为货币。天哪。这些玛丽亚·特蕾莎银币。出于某种原因，它们在东非已经根深蒂固并被接受了。但维也纳不再生产它们了。纳皮尔的特工，首先，纳皮尔派特工到中欧去购买尽可能多的
many of these old coins as they can. And then he sends a representative to the official mint in Vienna to persuade them. He said the British will supply you with silver and can you produce these talas? And the official mint in Vienna is turning out 20,000 of these a week, purely for the expeditionary force. God, amazing. So all this takes a lot of money. Derbiz government has set a budget of two million pounds. even before they set off, it balloons to 4 million, and it ends up costing the British taxpayer
这些旧硬币。然后他派了一名代表去维也纳的官方造币厂说服他们。他说英国将提供白银，你们能生产这些塔勒吗？维也纳的官方造币厂每周生产2万枚，专门供应给远征军。上帝，太神奇了。所以这一切需要很多钱。德比政府设定了200万英镑的预算。甚至在他们出发之前，它就膨胀到了400万，最终花费了英国纳税人
10 million pounds. So when you do the calculation, that is the equivalent of tens of billions of pounds today. This was an extremely expensive enterprise by the standards of the day. So can I just ask, this is a surgical strike. They have no plans to occupy Abyssinia or anything like that. It's in and out. No talk of regime change, no talk of anything. but the hostages. And secondly, they are doing this ultimately, you think, not for humanitarian reasons, but to affirm the prestige of the British Empire in the face of the Ottomans, the French. That's ultimately the reason.
1000万英镑。所以当你做计算时，这相当于今天数百亿英镑。按当时的标准来看，这是一项极其昂贵的企业。所以我能问一下，这是一次外科手术式的打击吗？他们没有占领阿比西尼亚的计划或类似的东西。就是进去然后出来。没有谈论政权更迭，没有谈论任何事情。除了人质。其次，你认为他们最终这样做不是出于人道主义原因，而是为了在奥斯曼帝国、法国人面前维护大英帝国的威望。这最终是原因。
Yes, I think it's hard to distinguish those two things. I think people at the time would have found it very hard to distinguish them. In the same way, let's go back to the comparison with Iran in 1980, the response to the Iranian Revolution and the hostage crisis. the plight of the hostages in that story became, you know, tear-jurking. It was on American newspapers and bulletins all the time. But it is also about prestige. But in the minds of the policymakers, it's inseparable, really, I guess.
是的，我认为很难区分这两件事。我认为当时的人们会发现很难区分它们。同样，让我们回到与1980年伊朗的比较，对伊朗革命和人质危机的反应。那个故事中人质的困境变得，你知道，令人泪下。它一直在美国的报纸和公告上。但它也关乎威望。但在决策者的心目中，它们确实是不可分割的。
And from the question of prestige, and I think the same is true here. Ultimately, I think they don't care that much about the hostages, about some missionaries. I mean, it's brilliant for the press, right? The press care. Yeah. But I think if your Lord Darby or Benjamin and Israeli, you care far more about British prestige. Britain cannot afford to be humiliated.
从威望的问题来看，我认为这里也是如此。最终，我认为他们并不那么关心人质，关心一些传教士。我的意思是，这对媒体来说很棒，对吧？媒体关心。是的。但我认为如果你是德比勋爵或本杰明·迪斯雷利，你更关心英国的威望。英国不能承受被羞辱的代价。
Because it is billions, billions and billions in today's spending. Yes. And we see now how governments hate spending money on the military. They do. But equally, governments sometimes think that there's a degree of face they cannot possibly lose. The humorous magazine Punch. They got a joke.
因为按今天的支出计算，这是数十亿、数十亿又数十亿。是的。我们现在看到政府是多么讨厌在军事上花钱。他们确实讨厌。但同样，政府有时认为有一种面子是他们绝对不能丢的。幽默杂志《笨拙》。他们开了一个玩笑。
Yeah, a slightly unamusing rhyme. But dash the expense, however immense, we can nothing cheaper than fight. And I think what they mean by that is the cost to the British people of losing face will ultimately be greater than that of the balance sheet that actually in the long run is better to pay the money now. Anyway, let's move forward to the autumn of 1867. So by the final week in October, the advance party, which is made up at Bombay Marines and Bombay like cavalry and engineers and sappers have landed in a place that they call Annesley Bay. And if you look it up, it is now the Gulf of Zula in Eritrea. They've found an anchorage for 100 ships, and then they send back measurement specifications for three large piers, which they will build, to help them unload the ships. And so in the next few weeks, more men, more supplies follow.
是的，一首稍微有点不好笑的打油诗。“但不管花费如何巨大，我们没有什么比战斗更便宜的了。”我想他们指的是失去面子对英国人民造成的代价最终将大于资产负债表上的数字，从长远来看，现在付钱实际上更好。总之，让我们进入1867年秋天。到10月的最后一周，由孟买海军陆战队、孟买轻骑兵、工程师和工兵组成的先遣队已经在他们称为安斯利湾的地方登陆了。如果你查一下，它现在是厄立特里亚的祖拉湾。他们为100艘船找到了锚地，然后他们发回了三座大型码头的测量规格，他们将建造这些码头来帮助他们卸货。所以在接下来的几周里，更多的人、更多的补给随之而来。
I mean, it's mind-boggling the enterprise. Hundreds of tons of coal. There are tramway sets. There's pile-driving machinery. And so by the new year of 1868, they have landed 13,000 soldiers, 20 miles of railway track, and 44 elephants, which were shipped across the Indian Ocean in specially reinforced transports. That is seven more elephants than Hannibal took. Really? Seven more to Italy, yeah. Harrah from Napier.
我的意思是，这项事业令人难以置信。数百吨煤炭。有电车轨道。有打桩机。所以到1868年新年，他们已经登陆了1.3万名士兵、20英里长的铁轨和44头大象，这些大象是用特别加固的运输船运过印度洋的。这比汉尼拔带的大象多了七头。真的吗？多七头到意大利，是的。为纳皮尔欢呼。
And while they're doing that, their sappers are literally blasting away through the cliffs to find the best route to get to the Highland Plateau. So they're going to have to head up 8,000 feet above sea level, and then they're going to have to travel through the kind of gorges and the ravines for another 350 miles until they get to Magdalar. On the 7th of January, Napier himself comes ashore from the SS Octavia. And Napier, like all, proficient commanders, has a great sense of theatre, political theatre. He is dressed in his full uniform. He's got all his medals. The ship's guns are firing a salute. There's a marine band playing. he comes ashore, everyone cheers.
当他们这样做的时候，他们的工兵正在字面上炸开悬崖，寻找到达高原的最佳路线。所以他们将不得不前往海拔8000英尺的地方，然后他们将不得不穿过峡谷和沟壑再走350英里，直到他们到达马格达拉。1月7日，纳皮尔本人从“奥克塔维亚”号轮船上岸。纳皮尔，像所有精干的指挥官一样，有很强的戏剧感，政治戏剧感。他穿着全套制服。他戴着所有的勋章。船上的大炮鸣放礼炮。有海军陆战队乐队在演奏。他上岸了，每个人都在欢呼。
And Napier is a, I mean, he's a very, very proficient commander. He's not bothered about the costs. He says, look, the government of India will pay and the British government will back them up. I want more mule drivers. My men need more boots. You know, his men love him for this reason. And within a couple of weeks, they have started work on the railway, and the railway will bring all their supplies inland from the coast.
纳皮尔是一个——我的意思是，他是一位非常、非常精干的指挥官。他不担心成本。他说，看，印度政府会付钱，英国政府会支持他们。我需要更多的骡夫。我的士兵需要更多的靴子。你知道，他的士兵因为这个原因而爱戴他。在几周内，他们就开始了铁路建设，铁路将把他们所有的补给从海岸运往内陆。
And they've also set up, I mean, this is an incredible achievement. They have basically a field telegraph all the way to their advance guard. They'll travel with that the whole way, basically unspooling copper wire as they go. So by the 25th of January 1868, Napier is ready to set off for the Great Trek to Magdalur. And as planned, he has 5,000 men that will go ahead as the spearhead. And behind, he has 7,000 men who will guard his supply lines. And as they set off, they must look absolutely outlandish to the locals.
他们还建立了——我的意思是，这是一项不可思议的成就。他们基本上有一条通往先遣卫队的野战电报线。他们将带着它全程旅行，基本上是一边走一边展开铜线。所以到1868年1月25日，纳皮尔准备开始前往马格达拉的伟大长征。正如计划的那样，他有5000人将作为先头部队前进。在后面，他有7000人将保卫他的补给线。当他们出发时，他们对当地人来说一定看起来非常古怪。
I mean, they must look, it must look like people have landed from Mars or something because the British cavalry lead the way. I want to say British, this is British and Indian. There are Sikhs,
我的意思是，他们一定看起来，一定看起来像是从火星降落的人，或者类似的东西，因为英国骑兵带头。我想说英国，这是英国和印度。有锡克教徒，
there are recruits from across the Indian subcontinent. So there's lots of, you know, people in turbines and stuff. But they're all wearing their British Army red jackets. Then there's a supply chain seven miles long behind them.
有来自整个印度次大陆的应征入伍者。所以有很多，你知道，戴着头巾的人之类的。但他们都穿着英国陆军的红色夹克。然后他们身后有一条七英里长的补给链。
There are the 44 elephants who are dragging the field guns, the kind of heavy guns. God, Tiodros would love that. Yeah, I mean, that's all his Christmas has come at once. And they have military bands playing the whole time. So, I mean, they're basically like a sort of roaming orchestra. And they trudge into the highlands, making very slow progress.
有44头大象在拖着野战炮，那种重炮。上帝，提奥多罗斯会喜欢那个的。是的，我的意思是，他所有的圣诞愿望都一次实现了。而且他们一直有军乐队在演奏。所以，我的意思是，他们基本上就像一个流动的管弦乐队。他们蹒跚地走进高原，进展非常缓慢。
Napier is, of course, conscious. The big issue that they face is if people attack them on routes, if the warlords attack them. And the key moment really comes at the end of February. so they've been on the road for a month or so. And he enters the territory of one of Teodros's key rivals, who is a guy called Raskasa, who is the king of Tigray, and basically the road to Magdalene runs through this kingdom of Tigray.
纳皮尔当然很清醒。他们面临的最大问题是如果人们在途中攻击他们，如果军阀攻击他们。关键时刻确实出现在2月底。所以他们在路上已经走了一个月左右。他进入了提奥多罗斯的主要竞争对手之一的领地，那个人叫拉斯卡萨，他是提格雷的国王，基本上通往马格达拉的道路穿过这个提格雷王国。
And Napier, he's a great diplomat. He waits for this guy. He stops. He waits. He wants to greet him with full military honours. He has his troops drawn up very smartly. When this bloke arrives, he says, would you like to inspect our guns? here I brought you presents. I've bought you an Arabian horse. I've got your rifle for you. I've got some nice glassware for you. And he says to Casa, my troops will not loot. They will not steal so much as a kind of, you know, a loaf of bread. We will pay for every sack of grain. If you help us, I promise you the friendship of Queen Victoria. And it works very well. This guy says to him, well, you're a very impressive person. He gives him a lion's skin cloak. And he says, I will bring you weekly support.
纳皮尔，他是一位伟大的外交家。他等待着这个人。他停下来。他等待。他想以全套军事荣誉迎接他。他让他的部队排得非常整齐。当这个家伙到达时，他说，你想检查我们的枪吗？这里我给你带来了礼物。我给你买了一匹阿拉伯马。我为你准备了步枪。我为你准备了一些漂亮的玻璃器皿。他对卡萨说，我的部队不会抢劫。他们甚至不会偷，你知道，一块面包。我们将为每一袋谷物付钱。如果你帮助我们，我向你保证维多利亚女王的友谊。这非常有效。这个家伙对他说，嗯，你是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。他给了他一件狮皮斗篷。他说，我会每周给你提供支持。
applies of food, which he does. And I think there's an implicit understanding here. It's never written down and it's never explicitly stated. But I think it's pretty clear. And Napier knows this man expects him to deal with Teodros once and for all. That that is the quid pro quo. You've been comparing this to the conquistadors in America. And this is a very familiar story, isn't it? Yeah. You know, whether it's the Aztecs or the Incas, that the local, not necessarily even subject peoples, but inferior rivals who want to throw off the hedony of the local big power that they team up with the Europeans. Exactly. I think that's exactly it. The difference, I guess, is that the British don't want to stay. You know, the conquistosos want to stay.
食物供应，他确实这样做了。我认为这里有一种隐含的理解。它从未被写下来，也从未被明确说明。但我认为这很清楚。纳皮尔知道这个人指望他一劳永逸地解决提奥多罗斯。这就是交换条件。你一直在把这与美国的征服者进行比较。这是一个非常熟悉的故事，不是吗？是的。你知道，无论是阿兹特克人还是印加人，当地的，不一定是臣民，但想要摆脱当地大国霸权的劣势竞争对手，他们与欧洲人结盟。正是如此。我认为这正是关键所在。我想区别在于英国人不想留下来。你知道，征服者想留下来。
They have their own agenda. The British really just didn't want to get in and get out. Now, this is probably a good point to ask, what has happened to the hostages? We haven't seen them for a while. So we last saw them in the summer of 1867, so almost a year ago. What have they been up to? They've been stuck in their huts at Magdala. They've been playing cards. I mean, they're kind of manacled, so I don't know how easy that is. I suppose they're bent over. I mean, cards is one thing if you're bent over. They've been reading the Bible. They're allowed to use all their old stores. And actually so they've been eating very well at Magdalene, because they brought up a lot of their old kind of stores and stuff. So insanely, they've been having like four course meals, soup, a starter, a main course and stuff.
他们有自己的议程。英国人真的只是想进去然后出来。现在，这可能是一个问“人质发生了什么”的好时机。我们有一段时间没见到他们了。他们一直在做什么？他们从1867年夏天，也就是将近一年前，就一直被困在马格达拉的小屋里。他们一直在打牌。我的意思是，他们被戴上了镣铐，所以我不知道这有多容易。我想他们是弯着腰的。我的意思是，如果你弯着腰，打牌是一回事。他们一直在读圣经。他们被允许使用他们所有的旧储备。实际上，他们在马格达拉吃得很好，因为他们带了很多旧的储备之类的东西。所以疯狂的是，他们一直在吃四道菜的饭，汤、开胃菜、主菜之类的。
So that's all, that's the good news. The bad news is they're still in chains. Some of them are very ill. They're very depressed. But then in December 1867, our traveller arrived in Magdala with a message for Dr. Blanc. And this was the news that the British had landed on the coast. the first British sort of engineers had landed on the coast. Dr. Blanc said later,
所以这就是好消息。坏消息是他们仍然戴着锁链。他们中的一些人病得很重。他们非常沮丧。但随后在1867年12月，我们的旅行者带着给布兰克医生的一条信息到达了马格达拉。这就是英国人在海岸登陆的消息。第一批英国工程师在海岸登陆了。布兰克医生后来这样说，
it was one of those exciting moments in a man's life that few can realize who have not passed through months of mental agony and then been suddenly overcome with joy. So it's incredibly exciting for the hostages. The British are on their way. But of course, they're now in a state of unbearable tension because Teodros has been gone for years, two years, almost. Will Teodros get back to Magdala before the British nation?
这是一个人一生中令人兴奋的时刻之一，很少有人能体会，除非他们经历了几个月的精神折磨，然后突然被喜悦所淹没。所以这对人质来说非常令人兴奋。英国人正在赶来。但当然，他们现在处于一种难以忍受的紧张状态，因为提奥多罗斯已经离开几年了，两年，几乎。提奥多罗斯会在英国人之前回到马格达拉吗？
And if so, will he have them all killed or will he agree to see sense? They don't know. And this, of course, brings us to Teodros himself. As I said, he's been gone for ages on campaign. He has been fighting rebels and stuff. But that autumn, 1867, he too began to head inland. He left his northern capital to head back to Magdala. And with him, he brought his army.
如果是这样，他会把他们全部杀掉，还是会同意讲道理？他们不知道。这当然把我们带到了提奥多罗斯本人身上。正如我所说，他已经在战役中离开很久了。他一直在与叛军作战之类的。但那年秋天，1867年，他也开始向内陆进发。他离开他的北方首都，准备回到马格达拉。他带着他的军队。
He brought a huge horde of camp followers. a huge horde of prisoners that he had taken. So he's got about 50,000 people with him. And above all, his favorite things, which are his guns. So listeners may remember that he was getting these Swiss and German missionaries to try and build guns for him. And they have finally managed to cast what he really wanted, which is a giant mortar.
他带着一大群随军家属。他带着一大群他俘虏的囚犯。所以他带着大约5万人。最重要的是，他最喜欢的东西，也就是他的枪。所以听众可能还记得他让那些瑞士和德国传教士试图为他制造枪支。他们终于成功铸造了他真正想要的东西，那是一门巨大的迫击炮。
And this is a 70-ton mortar. Its mouth is two feet wide. so it's a huge calibre. And he calls it Sebastopol because he loves the Crimean War. So Napier had been told Teodros has got these guns.
这是一门70吨重的迫击炮。它的口径有两英尺宽。所以这是一个巨大的口径。他称它为“塞瓦斯托波尔”，因为他热爱克里米亚战争。所以纳皮尔被告知提奥多罗斯有这些枪。
Napier assumed, well, when Seodros goes back to Magdala, he'll obviously leave these guns behind because they're so heavy and he's not going to try and drag them. But no, Tjordos is dragging these guns back to Magdal, and he's very excited about the chance of using them.
纳皮尔假设，嗯，当提奥多罗斯回到马格达拉时，他显然会把这些枪留下，因为它们太重了，他不会试图拖着它们。但不，提奥多罗斯正拖着这些枪回到马格达拉，他非常兴奋有机会使用它们。
Can I ask Dominic, these missionaries, these Swiss and German missionaries, Obviously, making guns we said in the first episode isn't really part of what they're about. No. But have they up their game by this point? Are these functioning? Well, that is a great question. And do you know what?
我能问一下多米尼克，这些传教士，这些瑞士和德国传教士，显然，制造枪支我们第一集说过并不是他们真正要做的事情。不。但他们到这个时候水平提高了吗？这些枪能用吗？嗯，这是一个很好的问题。你知道吗？
We're going to find out. We're going to find out what happens. Because Teodros has not yet fired it. Teodros has experimented a little bit with these guns, but he's never really fired them in anger. Okay, exciting. And this is something for listeners to look forward to. Now, he knows at this point, so let's say with the beginning of 1868, he knows. the British have landed. His agents have intercepted messages from Napier to the local chiefs.
我们会发现的。我们会发现发生了什么。因为提奥多罗斯还没有开过火。提奥多罗斯对这些枪做了一些实验，但他从未真正愤怒地开过火。好的，令人兴奋。这是听众可以期待的事情。现在，他此时知道，所以让我们说在1868年初，他知道。英国人已经登陆了。他的特工截获了纳皮尔发给当地酋长的信息。
You know, basically trying to get the local chief's support. Chaudros's reaction, people who are fans of his erratic behavior, will be pleased to hear that he reacts in a very peculiar way. So first of all, he says to his German missionary gunsmiths. He says, this is brilliant. The one thing I've always wanted to see is a really disciplined European army and finally I'm going to get the chance. So his plan appears to be, that he will get to Magdalore first, he will line up all his guns, then he will test them against the British army. He thinks that when the British see Sebastopol in action, they will respect him and they will see what a great king he is and what an impressive person here is, and they'll definitely
你知道，基本上是试图获得当地酋长的支持。提奥多罗斯的反应，那些喜欢他古怪行为的粉丝会很高兴听到他以一种非常奇特的方式做出反应。所以首先，他对他的德国传教士枪匠说。他说，这太棒了。我一直想看到的一件事就是一支纪律严明的欧洲军队，终于我得到了机会。所以他的计划似乎是，他会先到达马格达拉，他会排好他所有的枪，然后他会用它们来测试英国军队。他认为当英国人看到“塞瓦斯托波尔”在行动时，他们会尊重他，他们会看到他是一位多么伟大的国王，他是一个多么令人印象深刻的人，他们肯定会
want to come to an arrangement with him and perhaps sign a treaty. This is his thinking. He tells his courtiers, he says, I've heard a prophecy that a European king will meet with an Ethiopian king in this country. And after this, a great king will come. But I don't know whether I shall be that great king or someone else. That's modest of him. Yeah. Even so, you know, he's very keen, he's very excited. He's also started rebombarding his old crush, Hormuzd Rassam, the British agent, the guy from Mosul who used to be an archaeologist and the British descent. But is he still chained up at this point. He's chained up at Magdalya in the mountain lair, but Teodros has started writing, sending him love letters again. I mean, and the same thing to write to somebody who you
想要与他达成协议，也许签署一项条约。这就是他的想法。他告诉他的朝臣，他说，我听到一个预言，一位欧洲国王将在这个国家与一位埃塞俄比亚国王会面。在此之后，一位伟大的国王将会出现。但我不知道我是否会是那位伟大的国王还是别人。这对他来说很谦虚。是的。即便如此，你知道，他非常热衷，他非常兴奋。他还开始重新轰炸他以前的迷恋对象，霍尔穆兹·拉萨姆，那位英国特工，那个来自摩苏尔、曾经是考古学家和英国后裔的人。但他此时还被锁着吗？他被锁在马格达拉的山顶巢穴里，但提奥多罗斯又开始写信，再次给他发情书。我的意思是，给一个你
were keeping as a hostage. How are you? How are you, my friend? The nearer I approach towards you, the happier I feel. Oh, my friend, do not think I bear any hatred towards you. I've placed you in a present position in order that I may come to know the people of your country. It's kind of the opposite of the Stockholm syndrome, isn't it? Yeah, where you're captain. The captor falls in love with the captive. Yeah, exactly, exactly. And the maddest thing, the maddest thing is Teodros says to him, the thing I'm really looking forward to is I can't wait to show you Sebastopol.
一直扣押为人质的人写信，这太疯狂了。“你好吗？你好吗，我的朋友？我越接近你，我就越感到快乐。哦，我的朋友，不要认为我对你有任何仇恨。我把你放在现在的位置是为了让我了解你国家的人民。”这有点像斯德哥尔摩综合症的反面，不是吗？是的，绑架者爱上了被绑架者。是的，完全正确，完全正确。最疯狂的事情是提奥多罗斯对他说，我真正期待的事情是我迫不及待地想向你展示“塞瓦斯托波尔”。
I have had a large mortar cast, which is to tame me on the road. But when I reach Magdalar and you see it and admire it, I will forget all the trouble it has given me. So basically, Sebastopol for Teodros is a bit like the owl man for the Aztecs. Yes, it is. It's the ultimate weapon that will, that will, that will definitely win him the war. It will win him the war and also win him the undying affection of Rassam.
我铸造了一门大迫击炮，它是为了在路上驯服我而准备的。但当我到达马格达拉，你看到它并赞赏它时，我会忘记它给我带来的所有麻烦。所以基本上，对于特奥德罗斯来说，塞瓦斯托波尔有点像阿兹特克人的猫头鹰人。是的，确实如此。这是终极武器，它将，它将，它绝对会为他赢得战争。它将为他赢得战争，也将为他赢得拉萨姆永恒的爱戴。
So finally, Tiodorus arrives at the mountaintop on the 27th of March 1868. It's a very gothic scene. So a storm is breaking overhead, thunder, pouring rain. He arrives in the mountaintop and his guards immediately bring in Rassam. And Rassam is shocked to see that Tiodros has aged a lot in the last couple of years. He looks very gaunt, very haggard. Now, Rassam probably hasn't aged brilliantly because he's been chained up in a hut.
最终，特奥德罗斯于1868年3月27日到达山顶。那是一个非常哥特式的场景。头顶上风暴正在酝酿，雷声隆隆，大雨倾盆。他到达山顶，他的卫兵立即带上了拉萨姆。拉萨姆很震惊地发现，特奥德罗斯在过去几年里苍老了许多。他看起来非常憔悴，非常枯槁。现在，拉萨姆本人可能也没老得很好，因为他一直被锁在小屋里。
But Tiodros has been off on campaign. His mental health isn't great, to be honest. And he greets Rassam, his hostage, against the backdrop of the British invasion of his country, with the mad greeting, today we must all be English. And what does he mean by that? God knows.
但特奥德罗斯一直在外征战。老实说，他的心理健康状况不太好。在英国入侵他国家的背景下，他用一句疯狂的问候迎接了他的俘虏拉萨姆：“今天我们都必须是英国人。”他这话是什么意思？天知道。
Wear unsuitable clothing for the hot temperature. React to everything with sort of insusient, understatement. But that's not his style at all. No, he loves a voluble explosion. No, I think what he means by this, he means he's just, I think he just is so excited that the British are coming in a weird way. And he says, I can't wait to show you, Sebastopol. And he says, the two happiest days in my life are when Sebastopol was cast and also today, when I get to see you again. I mean, it's so unsettling. Callum, our producer, will enjoy this reference. There's a scene in I'm Alan Partridge, when Alan Partridge is effectively taken prisoner by a crazed fan called Jed.
穿着不适合高温天气的衣服。对一切都表现出一种漫不经心的、轻描淡写的态度。但这根本不是他的风格。不，他喜欢滔滔不绝的爆发。不，我想他这么说，是因为他，我想他只是太兴奋了，以至于英国人以一种奇怪的方式到来。他说：“我迫不及待地想向你展示塞瓦斯托波尔。”他说：“我一生中最快乐的两天，一是塞瓦斯托波尔铸造完成的时候，二就是今天，我又能见到你了。”我的意思是，这太令人不安了。我们的制片人卡勒姆会喜欢这个梗。在《我是艾伦·帕特里奇》里有一个场景，艾伦·帕特里奇实际上被一个叫杰德的疯狂粉丝俘虏了。
And this is basically Rassam's situation. He's been taken prisoner by Teodros. But then Teodros's mood changes abruptly, and he says to Rassam, I hope Mr. Rassam that when your people arrive, they will not despise me because I am black. And then a note of fatalism. One day you may see me dead. and while you stand by my corpse, it may be that you curse me for my bad conduct towards you.
这基本上就是拉萨姆的处境。他被特奥德罗斯俘虏了。但随后特奥德罗斯的情绪突然转变，他对拉萨姆说：“拉萨姆先生，我希望当你们的人到达时，他们不会因为我是黑人而鄙视我。”然后是一种宿命论的语气。“有一天你可能会看到我死去。当你站在我的尸体旁时，也许你会因为我之前对你的恶劣行为而诅咒我。”
Rassam, I think, finds it hard to know. Keep up with all this. Yeah, keep up. And the maddest thing of all, right? So, Tjodros, almost tearful with his love of Rassam and, you know, morbid thoughts and all this. And then as soon as his guards take Rassam out, Tjodros hurts his courteous and says very bitterly, Rassam has made asses of us and a fool of me. He's pretending to be my friend, but he's been plotting to slaughter us,
我想拉萨姆觉得很难跟上这一切。是的，跟上。最疯狂的事情是，对吧？特奥德罗斯因为对拉萨姆的爱而几乎流泪，你知道，还有那些病态的想法等等。然后，当他的卫兵把拉萨姆带走后，特奥德罗斯立刻变得刻薄起来，非常痛苦地说：“拉萨姆把我们当成了驴，把我当成了傻瓜。他假装是我的朋友，但他一直在密谋屠杀我们，
ravish our wives and reduce our people to bondage. It's kind of 16-year-old girl with a crush. I love him. I love him. He hates me. Yeah, that's exactly what it is. Yeah. That's exactly what it is.
蹂躏我们的妻子，并让我们的子民沦为奴隶。”这有点像一个暗恋中的16岁女孩。我爱他。我爱他。他恨我。是的，就是这样。是的。确实就是这样。
This is exactly his attitude to Rassan. Now, that's Teotros. General Napier, a very different kind of man with his... his moustache and his keen interest in engineering project. Exactly. His men have now trudged all the way to the edge of the Jitter Gorge, which is about 50 miles from Magdalene. We're now early April.
这正是他对拉萨姆的态度。现在，那是特奥德罗斯。纳皮尔将军，一个完全不同的人，留着他的……胡子，对工程项目有着浓厚的兴趣。没错。他的士兵们现在已经跋涉到了吉特峡谷的边缘，距离马格达拉大约50英里。现在是四月初。
So this is very sort of sun scorched, barren terrain. It's hard work now. They're a long way from the coast. They've travelled more than 300 miles. And on the 6th of April, they get their first glance of the summit of Magdala in the distance. So one war correspondent said it rose like a great... ship out of the surrounding billows. A napier now sends ahead a messenger with a final ultimatum.
所以这是一种被太阳灼烧的贫瘠地形。现在工作很辛苦。他们离海岸很远。他们已经走了300多英里。4月6日，他们第一次在远处看到了马格达拉的山顶。一位战地记者说，它像一艘巨大的……船从周围的波涛中升起。纳皮尔现在派出一名信使带着最后通牒先行一步。
By command of the Queen of England, I am approaching Magdalene with my army in order to recover from your hands, envoy Rassam, consul Cameron, Dr Blanc, Lieutenant Predo and the other Europeans now in your Majesty's power. I request your Majesty to send them to my camp as soon as is sufficiently near to admit of their coming in safety. There is no reply. But Teodros does know that the British are very close now. Every morning, Teodros very excitedly has been scanning the mountains with his telescope. Is that the telescope he got given? Yeah.
“奉英国女王之命，我正率军接近马格达拉，以从你手中救回拉萨姆特使、卡梅伦领事、布兰克医生、普雷多中尉以及其他目前在你陛下权力之下的欧洲人。我请求陛下在足够近以确保他们安全的情况下，将他们送到我的营地。”没有回复。但特奥德罗斯确实知道英国人现在非常近了。每天早上，特奥德罗斯都非常兴奋地用望远镜扫描群山。那是他得到的那个望远镜吗？是的。
He's thrown it away. He said he didn't smash it. No, clearly it didn't break. He's been staring through his telescope. And on the 7th of April, which is the Tuesday before Easter, he sees the first red British uniforms on the other side of the Bechilo Gorge. And he shouts, perhaps unexpected. He shouts very loudly with excitement when he sees them.
他把它扔了。他说他没把它砸碎。不，显然它没坏。他一直盯着望远镜看。4月7日，也就是复活节前的星期二，他在贝奇洛峡谷的另一边看到了第一批红色的英国军服。他大喊，也许是出乎意料。当他看到他们时，他兴奋地大声喊叫。
He shouts, hurrah, there go the donkeys. The donkeys are the British? Not all these mules that Napers had brought over. The British have got mules with them, so maybe that's what he's talking about. Who knows? And then he hands the telescope to this Swiss missionary called Theophilus Valbier, who is very keen on. And he says to Valbar in a very jaunty way,
他喊道：“万岁，驴子们来了。”驴子是指英国人？不是纳皮尔带来的那些骡子。英国人带着骡子，所以也许这就是他在说的。谁知道呢？然后他把望远镜递给了一位叫西奥菲勒斯·瓦尔比尔的瑞士传教士，他对此非常热衷。他以一种非常轻快的方式对瓦尔比尔说：
there you will see your brethren who have come from England to kill me. Trela. Yeah. So the next day is a Wednesday. Wednesday. Teodros gets up before dawn. Now, usually he dressed quite austerely with a white robe and a red border. But today, because the British have come, he's very excited. He's wearing, we're told, a silk, gold-threaded robe with white pantaloons. And Rassam said, rather disparagingly, he looked more like a harlequin than a sovereign. It's something really sad about that.
“在那里你会看到你的同胞，他们从英国来杀我。”特雷拉。是的。所以第二天是星期三。星期三。特奥德罗斯在黎明前起床。通常他穿得很朴素，穿着白袍，镶着红边。但今天，因为英国人来了，他非常兴奋。我们被告知，他穿着一件丝绸金线长袍，配着白色灯笼裤。拉萨姆相当轻蔑地说，他看起来更像个小丑而不是君主。这其中有些东西真的很可悲。
I know. He's trying to look regal. He's trying to make a splash, only to be the victim of massive British snobbery. Yeah, he's dressed inappropriately. And Rassam has obviously become very naturalised. You know who Teodros will get on absolutely superbly with? And it's a man, we're always pleased to get back on this podcast. The Kaiser. The Kaiser.
我知道。他试图看起来像个国王。他试图引起轰动，结果却成了英国人傲慢自大的受害者。是的，他穿得不合适。拉萨姆显然已经变得非常本土化了。你知道特奥德罗斯会和谁相处得非常好吗？这是一个我们总是很高兴在播客中提到的男人。凯撒。凯撒。
He and the Kaiser would have got on so well. There are similarities, sir. At this point, Teodros orders that all the prisoners be brought down. He's got a military camp lower down the mountain. And he has all the prisoners brought down. So this is the hostages, but also this great horde of Ethiopian captives. So these are, as I said before, captured rebels, rival chiefs, criminals, all of this. And these blokes, he's treated very badly, they're ravaged by disease and half-starved.
他和凯撒会相处得很好。先生，有相似之处。此时，特奥德罗斯下令将所有囚犯带下来。他在山下有一个军营。他让所有囚犯都被带下来。所以这不仅是人质，还有这大批埃塞俄比亚俘虏。正如我之前所说，这些是被俘的叛军、敌对酋长、罪犯等等。这些家伙，他对待他们非常糟糕，他们饱受疾病折磨，半饥半饱。
And Teodros says, you know, this is a little gesture to the British, choose 70 of these Abyssinian captives and let them go. And so they let these people go. They go off and head off towards the British. And then Teodros draws up his army and he gives a truly deranged speech to his army. He starts to inspire them. He says, the British are coming, and be in no doubt the British are much better than we are. They are better equipped and they're stronger. Their very dress is bedecked with gold to say nothing of their treasures, which can only be borne by elephants.
特奥德罗斯说，你知道，这是对英国人的一个小姿态，挑选70名阿比西尼亚俘虏，放了他们。于是他们放了这些人。他们离开并向英国人走去。然后特奥德罗斯集结了他的军队，并对他的军队发表了一场真正疯狂的演讲。他开始激励他们。他说：“英国人来了，毫无疑问，英国人比我们强得多。他们装备更好，更强大。他们的衣服上装饰着黄金，更不用说他们的财宝了，那些财宝只能由大象来搬运。”
Are you ready to fight and enrich yourselves with the spoils of these white slaves? Or will you disgrace me by running away? I mean, that's a sort of a leap. He's gone from saying the British are better to saying, we'll get all their treasure. and a kind of grizzled old veteran steps forward and says, only wait to your majesty until those asses make their appearance, and we will tear them to pieces. And everybody shouts,
“你们准备好战斗并用这些白奴的战利品来充实自己了吗？还是你们要通过逃跑来羞辱我？”我的意思是，这是一种飞跃。他从说英国人更好变成了说，我们将得到他们所有的财宝。一个满脸沧桑的老兵走上前说：“陛下，只等那些驴子出现，我们就会把他们撕成碎片。”每个人都喊道：
Hazar! Yay! And Teotvost greets that by saying to this man, you old fool, have you ever seen an English soldier before you know where you are, your belly will be filled with bullets. Oh my God, it's like Henry the Fifth Attaching Corps. So if you're one of his,
“哈扎尔！耶！”特奥德罗斯对此的回应是对这个人说：“你这个老傻瓜，你以前见过英国士兵吗？在你意识到之前，你的肚子里就会填满子弹。”天哪，这就像亨利五世在阿金库尔战役。所以如果你是他的，
men. He's sending very mixed messages. He is. Yes. He is. It was slightly deflated, I think. So the next day, Thursday, Thursday before Easter. Tiodros has been drinking a lot, probably too much, I think. And he drinks a lot that morning. And after lunch, he decides to retire to sleep it off. Now, before that, he said to his generals, okay, you can release all the remaining Abyssinian prisoners. Release them all now. Now these people have all been shackled up as well. I mean, the people manufacturing chains in the kingdom of Abyssinia must be making an absolute killing.
手下。他发出了非常矛盾的信息。确实。是的。他。我想这稍微泄了点气。所以第二天，星期四，复活节前的星期四。特奥德罗斯喝了很多酒，我想可能太多了。那天早上他喝了很多。午饭后，他决定去睡觉醒酒。在那之前，他对他的将军们说：“好吧，你们可以释放所有剩余的阿比西尼亚囚犯。现在就把他们都释放了。”现在这些人也都戴着镣铐。我的意思是，在阿比西尼亚王国制造锁链的人一定赚翻了。
And it's taking ages to get all their shackles off. And about four o'clock that afternoon, a very hungover to Jodros is woken by the sound of prisoners complaining that the guards are taking too long to get their shackles off. Chodros goes berserk of this. He calls for a sword and he immediately stabs two of the prisoners. to death. Then he says, how many are left? This is about 300 left. He says, bring them all up to me. They line them all up on the cliff. And then one by one, he has them thrown over the cliff to their deaths. And then he tells the guards, go down and finish all the survivors off. The whole thing
而且解开他们所有的镣铐花了好长时间。那天下午四点左右，宿醉未醒的特奥德罗斯被囚犯们的抱怨声吵醒，他们抱怨守卫解开镣铐花的时间太长了。特奥德罗斯对此大发雷霆。他要了一把剑，立即刺死了两名囚犯。然后他说：“还剩多少人？”大约还剩300人。他说：“把他们都带到我面前。”他们把他们都排在悬崖边上。然后一个接一个，他让他们被扔下悬崖摔死。然后他告诉守卫，下去把所有幸存者都干掉。整件事
takes two hours. It's a horrendous scene, obviously. But your trust does feel bad about it afterwards, because that evening, apparently one of his servants heard him praying aloud, telling God, confessing to God that he was drunk when he ordered the massacre and asking for forgiveness, saying, please don't count it against me because drink had been taken. I don't know what God's view of that was, actually. I don't think very approving, to be honest. Surely not. So we come to the crucial day, and this is the 11th of April 1868.
花了两个小时。这显然是一个可怕的场景。但特奥德罗斯事后确实感到难过，因为那天晚上，显然他的一名仆人听到他大声祈祷，向上帝忏悔，承认他在下令屠杀时喝醉了，并请求宽恕，说：“请不要记在我的账上，因为我喝了酒。”我不知道上帝对此有什么看法，真的。老实说，我不认为会很赞同。肯定不会。所以我们来到了关键的一天，这就是1868年4月11日。
It is Good Friday. Teodros knows that the British are very close now. He knows that they are about to reach in a few hours the plateau of Aroji, which is just below the fortress at Magdala. They should be there by the afternoon and this will be it. This will be a moment of decision. And we will find out what happens in that moment of decision after the break. This episode is sponsored by how the Tudors lost their heads on National Geographic.
那是耶稣受难日。特奥德罗斯知道英国人现在非常近了。他知道他们再过几个小时就要到达马格达拉堡垒下方的阿罗吉高原了。他们应该在下午到达，这就是决定性的时刻。我们将在休息后找出那个决定性时刻发生了什么。本集由国家地理频道的《都铎王朝如何失去头颅》赞助。
You and I think we know the story of the Tudors, don't we? But this series puts them in a very different light because it asks, What if the biggest Tudor stories were investigated like modern true crime cases? A brilliant idea. So just to emphasise, this is very much not a traditional history documentary. And we could not be more excited about it. So this is a series that explores some of the best known figures of the Tudor era and also some of the less well-known. And it uncovers fresh evidence that shines a new light on the stories behind their demise. Yeah, I'd really love to get into some of these Tudor stories.
你和我以为我们了解都铎王朝的故事，对吧？但这个系列以一种非常不同的视角审视他们，因为它问：如果最大的都铎王朝故事像现代真实犯罪案件一样被调查会怎样？一个绝妙的主意。所以要强调的是，这绝不是一部传统的历史纪录片。我们对此感到无比兴奋。所以这是一个探索都铎时代一些最著名人物以及一些不太知名人物的系列。它揭示了新的证据，为他们灭亡背后的故事提供了新的视角。是的，我真的很想深入了解其中一些都铎王朝的故事。
You know that the one that's always fascinated me as Hem of the 8th and is ulcer. I'd like to have forensic scientists looking at it, how he got the ulcer, how it was treated. I don't know if that's one of the cases they're doing, but I know they're doing the absolute best cases, so it probably will be. Well, Dominic, the only way to find out is to watch how the Tudors lost their heads on Sunday at 8pm on National Geographic. and Russia. We assess Prime Minister, with high confidence it was Russian. Holding the Russians accountable is World War III. They took down a British passenger jet containing 350 people.
你知道那个一直让我着迷的是亨利八世和他的溃疡。我想让法医科学家研究一下，他是怎么得的溃疡，它是怎么治疗的。我不知道这是否是他们正在做的案件之一，但我知道他们正在做最好的案件，所以很可能就是。好吧，多米尼克，唯一的办法就是观看周日晚上8点在国家地理频道播出的《都铎王朝如何失去头颅》。还有拉萨姆。我们评估总理，有高度信心是俄罗斯人。让俄罗斯人负责就是第三次世界大战。他们击落了一架载有350人的英国客机。
Man in the Kremlin is playing, Alex. Got to ask yourself, you want to play or not? You're the Prime Minister. You've done... Nothing! We would need to understand the policy context. All the relevant context will be structured as a framework today. day and disseminated into an operation order, or Fraggo.
克里姆林宫的那个人在玩弄，亚历克斯。你得问问自己，你想玩还是不想玩？你是总理。你做了……什么都没做！我们需要了解政策背景。所有相关的背景将在今天构建为一个框架，并分发到作战命令或Fraggo中。
A Fragor that says to kill the president of Russia. Yes. New from Goldhanger. Who is going to be able to pull this off? You're my soldier, are you? Sergeant Tom McDuff, Duffy. An audio drama journey like no other. Men like Duffy, they are our most valuable weapons. Devised as a technically rigorous, geopolitical action,
一个说要杀死俄罗斯总统的Fragor。是的。来自Goldhanger的新作。谁能完成这个任务？你是我的士兵，对吧？汤姆·麦克达夫中士，达菲。一段与众不同的音频剧旅程。像达菲这样的人，是我们最宝贵的武器。被设计为一种技术严谨的、地缘政治行动，
where Britain plays its strongest hand. He's the best. Against its strongest foe. Bear Hunt. Available now wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back to the rest of history, where it is Good Friday, 1868, and the Emperor Teodros is preparing for his final showdown with Lieutenant General Sir Robert Napier. And the two generals are very different characters. aren't they Dominic?
英国在这里打出了最强的一手牌。他是最棒的。对抗它最强大的敌人。猎熊。现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听。欢迎回到历史的其余部分，现在是1868年的耶稣受难日，特奥德罗斯皇帝正在为他与罗伯特·纳皮尔中将的最后决战做准备。这两位将军是截然不同的角色，不是吗，多米尼克？
They are. They could not be more different. Napier's probably been studying engineering measurements overnight. Teodros's drinking, feeling bad that he's been massacring people, throwing them off cliffs. He gets up early and he goes to church. Then he orders, all the European hostages are still at his lower camp. He says, I've changed my mind. Take them all back up to the top at Magdler.
他们是。他们不可能更不同了。纳皮尔可能整晚都在研究工程测量。特奥德罗斯在喝酒，因为屠杀人们、把他们扔下悬崖而感到难过。他起得很早，去了教堂。然后他下令，所有欧洲人质仍然在他的下营地。他说：“我改变主意了。把他们都带回马格达拉的山顶。”
I mean, all they have been doing for about the past two years is trudging up and down this map. It's a miserable business. They've had a very confusing time, I think. Yeah. Rassam, who's still on talking, speaking terms with him, says to him, please, this is probably your last chance to ask General Napier for terms. And Teodros says, I will do no such thing as he has been sent by a woman. Meaning Queen Victoria.
我的意思是，过去两年他们一直在地图上走来走去。这是一件悲惨的事情。我想他们度过了一段非常困惑的时光。是的。拉萨姆，仍然和他保持着交谈，对他说：“请，这可能是你最后一次向纳皮尔将军要求谈判的机会了。”特奥德罗斯说：“我绝不会这样做，因为他是被一个女人派来的。”指的是维多利亚女王。
So he was all talk about Queen Victoria beforehand. Yeah. It's not very gallant at all. No, exactly. He's led himself down there. That's very poor from Teodros. Chodros now divides his forces. He will stay on the heights with his guns, which he's very excited about, and the rest of his men,
所以他之前一直在谈论维多利亚女王。是的。这根本不怎么绅士。不，确实。他让自己陷入了那种境地。特奥德罗斯的表现太差了。特奥德罗斯现在分开了他的部队。他将带着他的大炮留在高地上，他对此非常兴奋，而他的其余部下，
so he's got about 7,000 sort of loyalists. He wants them to charge the British as soon as the British arrive on the plateau. And he gives them a slightly disconcerting send-off, as is his want. He says to them, take leave of your families, for today you will have the honour to die with a king. So Churchillian. Now meanwhile, Napier's men are climbing onto the plain of Eroji and they're climbing up through this valley in punishing heat. It's a really grueling march. I mean, they've come a hell of a long way. They're in these very heavy packs. They haven't got much water. The weather, I mean, you know, the gods have written the story. There is thunder in the air. The storm is going to break. It's a very ominous atmosphere. And of course, I already mentioned the best known British intervention. overseas at this point is probably still 1842 Afghanistan. This is the obvious parallel. They know that these things don't always end well, despite their technological superiority.
所以他大约有7000名效忠者。他希望他们在英国人到达高原时立即冲锋。他给了他们一个稍微令人不安的送别，正如他所愿。他对他们说：“和你们的家人告别吧，因为今天你们将有幸与一位国王一起死去。”太丘吉尔了。与此同时，纳皮尔的士兵们正在爬上阿罗吉平原，他们在酷热中穿过这个山谷。这是一次非常艰苦的行军。我的意思是，他们走了很远的路。他们背着这些非常沉重的背包。他们没有多少水。天气，我的意思是，你知道，上帝写了这个故事。空气中有雷声。风暴即将爆发。这是一种非常不祥的气氛。当然，我已经提到了目前为止最著名的英国海外干预可能仍然是1842年的阿富汗。这是一个明显的平行。他们知道这些事情并不总是以好的结果结束，尽管他们有技术优势。
Henry Morton-Standley war correspondent said at the time, he remembered this terrible, suspicious silence as they advanced up the valley onto the plateau. And I think a lot of them probably are thinking, this has got kind of Afghanistan Mark II, written all over it. At some point, people will emerge over their horizon and we will all be butchered. I mean, part of the kind of the vibe of the Afghan war was British soldiers in red uniforms being shot at by snipers from behind rocks and things like that. This is a key moment in the history of the British Army, isn't it? Because they are not wearing their red coats. Exactly, right. Exactly. They have brought along with them for the first time
亨利·莫顿·斯坦利战地记者当时说，他记得当他们沿着山谷推进到高原时，那种可怕的、可疑的沉默。我想他们中的许多人可能在想，这简直就是阿富汗战争的翻版。在某个时刻，人们会出现在地平线上，我们都会被屠杀。我的意思是，阿富汗战争的那种氛围的一部分就是穿着红色制服的英国士兵被躲在岩石后面的狙击手射击等等。这是英国陆军历史上的一个关键时刻，不是吗？因为他们没有穿红外套。没错，对吧。完全正确。他们第一次随身携带了
in combat, khaki battle uniforms. As you say, previously they had worn their kind of bright, resplendent red, but they finally decided to compromise with the reality. And since the first time that a British army has gone into combat wearing khaki. They don't all wear khaki, I think, but certainly a proportion of them do. So they're now stumbling out. It's about four o'clock onto this plane from the valley. And on the heights above, Teodros has been watching their advice.
在战斗中，卡其色作战服。正如你所说，以前他们穿的是那种明亮、灿烂的红色，但他们最终决定向现实妥协。这是英国军队第一次穿着卡其色投入战斗。我想他们并不是都穿卡其色，但肯定有一部分人穿了。所以他们现在从山谷里跌跌撞撞地走出来，大约四点钟到达这个平原。而在上方的高地上，特奥德罗斯一直在观察他们的动向。
And now he sees them coming and he shouts to his men. Be not afraid of these English soldiers because they are like the Philistines who made war against David. But remember David smoked them and in the name of God I shall conquer. Look at those slaves. They're women. Look at them. They bring you clothes and riches and pay. Go down and help yourselves.
现在他看到他们来了，他向他的部下大喊：“不要害怕这些英国士兵，因为他们就像那些与大卫作战的非利士人。但记住大卫击败了他们，以神的名义，我必将征服。看看那些奴隶。他们是女人。看看他们。他们给你们带来衣服、财富和报酬。下去，拿走你们想要的。”
And at this moment, you know, proper Hollywood stuff. The storm breaks. There's a great crash of thunder overhead. And at that moment, Teodra shouts to his gunners, open fire, and the first shells shriek through the air towards Napier's men. So some of the guns are working. And at that point, down below, the Abyssinian troops that have been waiting gave a great kind of cheer and a kind of war whoop. And they charge onto the plane themselves. Some of them on horseback, some of them running, they've leveled their spears, they're singing, their war songs.
就在这一刻，你知道，真正的好莱坞式的东西。风暴爆发了。头顶传来一声巨大的雷鸣。就在那一刻，特奥德罗斯向他的炮手大喊：“开火！”第一批炮弹尖叫着穿过空气飞向纳皮尔的士兵。所以有些大炮在工作。就在那时，在下方，一直等待的阿比西尼亚军队发出了一声巨大的欢呼和一种战争呐喊。他们自己冲上了平原。有些人骑着马，有些人跑着，他们平举着长矛，唱着他们的战歌。
it's the kind of ride of the Rahiram at the Battle of the Pelinor Fields or something and a tremendously rousing and exciting moment as they race towards the British. And for a moment, you know, if you're watching the film of this, it looks as if Teodros's plan has worked. It looks as if the British have walked right into a trap. They've walked into the guns. They've walked into the charge. And they're going to be swept off the plateau.
这就像佩里诺平原战役中洛汗骑兵的冲锋之类的，当他们冲向英国人时，这是一个非常振奋人心和激动人心的时刻。有一瞬间，你知道，如果你在看这部电影，看起来特奥德罗斯的计划奏效了。看起来英国人直接走进了陷阱。他们走进了大炮的射程。他们走进了冲锋。他们将被扫出高原。
But it doesn't quite work out that way. So first of all, the guns. These guns that he loved so much, I mean, never get a missionary to build you a gun. That's the lesson of history. Here's the lesson of history. A Swiss missionary. The guns are so inaccurate that the shells just sail over the heads of Napier and his men. Has he fired Sebastopol at this point?
但事情并没有完全那样发展。首先，大炮。他如此喜爱这些大炮，我的意思是，永远不要让传教士为你制造大炮。这就是历史的教训。这就是历史的教训。一位瑞士传教士。这些大炮非常不准确，以至于炮弹只是从纳皮尔和他的士兵头顶飞过。他此时发射了塞瓦斯托波尔吗？
I don't know that he ever does fire Sebastopol. Oh, no. But one of the guns early on, one of the guns explodes, that it bursts. And at this point, I think some of the gunners lost heart. Shoddy Swiss workmanship. Exactly. So often the way with the Swiss, isn't it? Yeah, isn't it?
我不知道他是否真的发射过塞瓦斯托波尔。哦，不。但其中一门大炮在早期爆炸了，它炸裂了。在这一点上，我想一些炮手失去了信心。劣质的瑞士工艺。确实如此。瑞士人经常这样，不是吗？是的，不是吗？
Now, meanwhile, the sort of his assault troops or whatever are charging at the British. Now, the British are taking aim with their rifles. But the Abyssinians know, yeah, they've charged guns before. They've charged riflemen before. They know that basically what will happen is the riflemen will fire, but then they'll have to reload. That's a massive faf. It takes them ages. And you can be on them and you can butcher them. But what they don't know is the British have a secret technological advantage. The British have bought for the first time state-of-the-art Snyder breech-loading rifles. So these are rifles that
现在，与此同时，他的突击部队之类的正在冲向英国人。现在，英国人正在用步枪瞄准。但阿比西尼亚人知道，是的，他们以前冲锋过大炮。他们以前冲锋过步枪手。他们知道基本上会发生什么，步枪手会开火，但然后他们必须重新装弹。那是一个巨大的麻烦。这需要很长时间。你可以冲到他们面前，屠杀他们。但他们不知道的是，英国人有一个秘密的技术优势。英国人第一次带来了最先进的斯奈德后装步枪。所以这些是步枪，
you can reload within seconds. Yeah. We have got the Snyder breech-loading rifle and they have not correct. And that means that collectively the British line can fire about 30 to 40 rounds a second. And there's no let up in the rate of fire. And so the Avicinians are charging towards them thinking at some point they're going to stop and they're going to reload and that moment never comes. The first to fall are the Abyssinian chiefs and kind of captains because they are wearing bright red kind of scarlet shirts. That is ironic. So they're sitting ducks. They are shot down. Their men keep coming and then the bullets just a hail of bullets just knock them down in their hundreds. And they keep charging. They
你可以在几秒钟内重新装弹。是的。我们有斯奈德后装步枪，而他们没有，对吧。这意味着英国防线总共每秒可以发射大约30到40发子弹。射速没有减弱。所以阿比西尼亚人冲向他们，认为在某个时刻他们会停下来重新装弹，但那一刻从未到来。最先倒下的是阿比西尼亚酋长和队长，因为他们穿着鲜红色的衬衫。这很讽刺。所以他们是活靶子。他们被射倒了。他们的人继续前进，然后子弹，仅仅是一阵子弹就把他们成百上千地击倒。他们继续冲锋。他们
keep charging again and again, the British just keep on firing. It is a total bloodbath. And from the heights, Teodros is watching and he just cannot believe it. So this continues for the next couple of hours. The last dusk begins to fall and the fighting dies down. And the survivors straggled back to Teodros' camp. And in the dark, he calls out to them, where is so-and-so, where's so-and-so, naming his chiefs? They're all dead. All the people he knows by name are dead. So in all, he's lost about a thousand men, just under a thousand men, thousands more wounded. The British have lost two men killed and about 20 wounded. I mean, you could hardly imagine a more lopsided battle. Teodros is stunned. I mean, the weird thing is
继续一次又一次地冲锋，英国人只是不停地开火。这是一场彻底的血洗。从高地上，特奥德罗斯看着，他简直不敢相信。所以这种情况持续了接下来的几个小时。黄昏开始降临，战斗平息了。幸存者跌跌撞撞地回到特奥德罗斯的营地。在黑暗中，他向他们喊道：“某某人在哪里，某某人在哪里？”叫着他酋长的名字。他们都死了。所有他叫得出名字的人都死了。所以总共，他损失了大约一千人，不到一千人，还有数千人受伤。英国人死了两个人，大约20人受伤。我的意思是，你几乎无法想象一场更一边倒的战斗。特奥德罗斯惊呆了。我的意思是，奇怪的是，
he always kind of knew, I think, that the British would be a tough challenge, but he didn't think they'd be this tough. And he retires to his tent in the sort of terrible silence. He doesn't know what to do. Does he free the hostages? Does he start killing the hostages? Does he try to run away? Well, when in doubt, send another of your letters to Rassam, I think is his general approach. So he sends Rassam another of his mad notes. How have you passed the day? Thank God, I am well. I, being a king, could not allow people to come and fight me without attacking them first. done so and my tributes have been beaten. I thought your people were women, but I find there are men. They fought very bravely. Seeing that I'm unable to withstand them, I must ask you to reconcile
他总是有点知道，我想，英国人会是一个艰难的挑战，但他没想到他们会这么强硬。他退回到他的帐篷里，陷入了一种可怕的沉默。他不知道该怎么办。他释放人质吗？他开始杀人质吗？他试图逃跑吗？好吧，当有疑问时，再给拉萨姆发一封信，我想这是他的一般方法。所以他给拉萨姆发了另一张疯狂的字条。“你今天过得怎么样？感谢上帝，我很好。我，作为一个国王，不能允许人们来攻击我而不先反击。我这样做了，我的贡品被击败了。我以为你们的人是女人，但我发现他们是男人。他们打得非常勇敢。鉴于我无法抵挡他们，我必须请你调解
me to them. And Rassam scribbles him a note and says, I completely agree. At dawn, I think you should send a delegation to Napier, maybe send that missionary, the Reverend Flad and Lieutenant Predo, and they can, you know, carry your peace offer to Napier. So that night, nobody can sleep because it's just a lot of wailing as the Abyssinians mourn they're dead. And at four o'clock in the morning, Teodros summons Flad and Predo, as Rassam suggested, and says, I want you to go down to the British camp and discuss peace. So they go down the hill.
我和他们之间的关系。”拉萨姆给他写了一张便条说：“我完全同意。黎明时分，我认为你应该派一个代表团去见纳皮尔，也许派那个传教士，弗拉德牧师和普雷多中尉，他们可以，你知道，把你的和平提议带给纳皮尔。”那天晚上，没有人能睡觉，因为阿比西尼亚人哀悼死者时发出了很多哀号。凌晨四点，特奥德罗斯召集了弗拉德和普雷多，正如拉萨姆建议的那样，说：“我要你们下到英国营地去讨论和平。”于是他们下了山。
They get onto the plane. The plane is covered with bodies, many of them being mangled by hyenas. So that's a bit disconcerting. under their white flag they get to the British camp and when the soldiers see them coming the soldiers will start cheering and they're taken straight to Napier and they say to Napier we've come from the emperor the emperor wants peace and Napier says brilliant and Napier dictates a very gracious reply he says your majesty has fought like a brave man and has been overcome by the superior power of the British army it is my desire that no more blood may be shed if therefore your majesty will submit to the Queen of England and bring all the
他们到达了平原。平原上到处都是尸体，许多被鬣狗撕碎。所以这有点令人不安。在白旗下，他们到达了英国营地，当士兵们看到他们走过来时，士兵们开始欢呼，他们被直接带到纳皮尔面前，他们对纳皮尔说：“我们来自皇帝，皇帝想要和平。”纳皮尔说：“太好了。”纳皮尔口述了一份非常亲切的回复，他说：“陛下像一个勇敢的人一样战斗，并被英国军队的优越力量所克服。我希望不再有流血事件。因此，如果陛下愿意向英国女王投降，并带来所有
Europeans now in your Majesty's hands and deliver them safely this day in the British camp, I guarantee honourable treatment for yourself and for all the members of your Majesty's family. And he says, Teodros has 24 hours to decide. So the delegation go back to Teodros. And he says, I don't really understand what he means. What does he mean by honourable treatment? Do they mean to treat me honourably as a prisoner? Or do they intend to assist me in recovering my country from the rebels?
目前在你陛下手中的欧洲人，并于今日将他们安全送到英国营地，我保证对你本人和你陛下家庭的所有成员给予体面的待遇。”他说，特奥德罗斯有24小时的时间来决定。于是代表团回到特奥德罗斯那里。他说：“我不太明白他的意思。他所说的体面待遇是什么意思？他们是打算把我当作囚犯来体面对待吗？还是他们打算协助我从叛军手中收复我的国家？”
And I think this is when he's got a real shock at this point because I think he always thought that the British would fight him, be impressed by him and his big gun. His guns, yeah. And then they would help him and they would be great friends. And now he thinks, I don't want to be taking it as a prisoner back to London. That is the last thing that I want. So he dictates this very rambling reply, no mention of the hostages. a lot of mention of how terrible the Abyssinian people are, a land of heathens, he describes his own country as.
我想这就是他此时感到真正震惊的时候，因为我想他一直认为英国人会和他战斗，对他和他的大炮印象深刻。他的大炮，是的。然后他们会帮助他，他们会成为好朋友。现在他想，我不想被当作囚犯带回伦敦。这是我最不想做的事情。所以他口述了这份非常杂乱的回复，没有提到人质。提到了很多关于阿比西尼亚人民是多么可怕，他将自己的国家描述为异教徒之地。
He says, you are brilliant people. You're a people governed by discipline. I'm very impressed with you. But he doesn't really give Napier a clear answer about the hostages. He sends this message to Napier's camp. Then he goes and sits on a rock alone. His men see him praying. They see him bow three times.
他说：“你们是杰出的人民。你们是一个受纪律约束的人民。我给你们留下了深刻的印象。”但他并没有真正给纳皮尔一个关于人质的明确答复。他把这个信息发到了纳皮尔的营地。然后他独自坐在一块岩石上。他的部下看到他在祈祷。他们看到他鞠了三次躬。
And then to their horror, they see him pull a pistol from his belt, and put it in his mouth and go to pull the trigger. And his officers rush at him and they yank his arm away. And he does fire, but the bullet just grazes his ear. I mean, you say to their horror, but I mean, he has led them into a complete disaster. So they're still loyal to him. But they must be horrified because they stop him shooting himself.
然后令他们惊恐的是，他们看到他从腰间拔出一把手枪，放进嘴里，准备扣动扳机。他的军官们冲向他，把他的手臂拉开了。他确实开火了，但子弹只是擦伤了他的耳朵。我的意思是，你说令他们惊恐，但我的意思是，他已经把他们带入了一场彻底的灾难。所以他们仍然忠于他。但他们一定很惊恐，因为他们阻止了他自杀。
Yeah. Because you'd think with all his ranting and his lunatic general behavior, they might think this isn't really the greatest war leader we've ever had. You might think that, but maybe some of them just think it's. It's fun. You never know where you are. No two days are the same. I don't know.
是的。因为你会认为他所有的咆哮和疯狂的将军行为，他们可能会认为这不是我们有过的最伟大的战争领袖。你可能会这么想，但也许他们中的一些人只是认为这很有趣。你永远不知道你在哪里。没有哪两天是相同的。我不知道。
Because he's busy chopping off hands and feet, isn't he, and throwing people to hyenas. Looting manuscripts. Yeah, he's doing that, of course. Maybe it's that. I don't know. He now throws himself to the ground. He's sobbing.
因为他忙着砍掉手脚，不是吗，还把人扔给鬣狗。掠夺手稿。是的，他当然在做那个。也许就是那个。我不知道。他现在把自己扔在地上。他在啜泣。
He's disconsolate. He's just in floods of tears. And then he tossed himself down. And for about the 17th time, he says, bring all the Europeans down from the mountaintop. It is hard to keep up, isn't it? it is. Yeah, I mean, you find it hard to keep up. Imagine having to make the notes. I mean, yeah, I'm trying to keep track of where everybody is. I thought you were going to say,
他很沮丧。他只是泪流满面。然后他把自己扔了下去。大约第17次，他说：“把所有欧洲人从山顶带下来。”很难跟上，不是吗？确实。是的，我的意思是，你觉得很难跟上。想象一下必须做笔记。我的意思是，是的，我正在努力跟踪每个人在哪里。我以为你要说，
imagine being a hostage, but no, you're the victim here. No, I'm the real victim, almost. Let's pretty clear. So the hostages are dragged back down. They're completely bewildered. It's very dark. It's a very sort of ominous scene. They're convinced that Teodros has gone completely mad and is going to kill them all. They get halfway down and then a guard stops them and he says, Mr. Rassam, please the rest of you stay here. Teodros wants to speak to Rassam alone. Rassam, who's very nervous, finds the emperor standing alone by the edge of the cliff.
想象一下成为人质，但没有，你是这里的受害者。不，我才是真正的受害者，几乎是。很清楚。所以人质被拖了回来。他们完全困惑了。天很黑。这是一个非常不祥的场景。他们确信特奥德罗斯已经完全疯了，要杀了他们所有人。他们走到一半，然后一个守卫拦住他们说：“拉萨姆先生，请你们其他人留在这里。特奥德罗斯想单独和拉萨姆谈谈。”拉萨姆，非常紧张，发现皇帝独自站在悬崖边。
And Teodros, as a broken man, says to him, you know, Mr. Rassam, that you and I have always been on good terms. I've always had a high regard for you. It's true I behave badly towards you, but that was because of the behaviour of bad men. And Teodros says, tomorrow, when I'm taken prisoner, please stand up for me in the British camp.
特奥德罗斯，作为一个破碎的人，对他说：“你知道，拉萨姆先生，你和我一直关系很好。我一直很看重你。我确实对你表现得很糟糕，但那是因为坏人的行为。”特奥德罗斯说：“明天，当我被俘虏时，请在英国营地为我求情。”
put a good word in for me. I want you to bear this in mind. Unless you befriend me, I should either kill myself or become a monk. Now, goodbye. It's getting late. Try to come and see me tomorrow if you can. And they shake hands and Rassam sees tears into Drodros's eyes. And Rassam goes on down the path. And Rassam is terrified that when he goes on down the path, he will find that all the other hostages have been butchered. But no, he meets up with the other hostages and they all now trudge on towards the British camp. And they pass through the British lines, great cheering. They've all been freed. It's an incredibly emotional scene. They're shown to Napier's tent. The British agent in Aden, who was called Colonel Meriwether,
“为我美言几句。我希望你记住这一点。除非你与我交好，否则我要么自杀，要么出家。现在，再见。天色已晚。如果可以的话，明天试着来看看我。”他们握了握手，拉萨姆看到特奥德罗斯眼中含着泪水。拉萨姆沿着小路走下去。拉萨姆很害怕，当他沿着小路走下去时，他会发现所有其他人质都被屠杀了。但没有，他遇到了其他人质，他们现在都向英国营地走去。他们穿过英国防线，欢呼声一片。他们都被释放了。这是一个令人难以置信的情感场景。他们被带到纳皮尔的帐篷。英国驻亚丁代理人，名叫梅里韦瑟上校，
has brought loads of champagne along just in case. See, I mentioned the champagne. I said that's why they brought the champagne. So they open the champagne. You know, it's all over, or is it? Not quite. The next day is used to Sunday. day. Teodros is still up on the hill, sends Napier another letter. Very erratic. He tells Napier that he's tried to kill himself. Satan placed in me the thought that I should die by my own gun. He says, as a peace offering, I'm going to send you a thousand cows and 500 sheep, which he does. And as the livestock is being led towards the British line, Teodros says to his officers, surely it is peace now. They've taken my power from me. Surely it is peace.
带了很多香槟以防万一。看，我提到了香槟。我说过这就是他们带香槟的原因。所以他们打开了香槟。你知道，一切都结束了，还是没有？第二天是星期日。特奥德罗斯还在山上，给纳皮尔发了另一封信。非常不稳定。他告诉纳皮尔他试图自杀。“撒旦在我心中种下了我应该死在自己枪下的念头。”他说，作为和平礼物，我要送给你一千头牛和500只羊，他确实这么做了。当牲畜被带向英国防线时，特奥德罗斯对他的军官们说：“现在肯定是和平了。他们已经夺走了我的权力。肯定是和平了。”
But now the tragic turning point in the story, Napier refuses to accept the cows and the sheep. And I think the reason he does this is he knows that under the local custom, if he accepts them, that means it's all over and he's accepted peace. And when Teodros sees Napier turning them away, he says bitterly to his courtiers, these people having got what they wanted, they now want to kill me. He flirts with the idea of fleeing. He says, you know, maybe we could run away, maybe we could get to Lake Tana. But his men say to him, no, we're not going to flee with you.
但现在是故事中悲剧性的转折点，纳皮尔拒绝接受牛和羊。我想他这样做的原因是，他知道根据当地习俗，如果他接受了它们，那就意味着一切都结束了，他接受了和平。当特奥德罗斯看到纳皮尔拒绝它们时，他痛苦地对他的朝臣说：“这些人得到了他们想要的，现在他们想杀我。”他萌生了逃跑的想法。他说：“你知道，也许我们可以逃跑，也许我们可以去塔纳湖。”但他的部下对他说：“不，我们不会和你一起逃跑。”
Your own, you've got to make peace now. We will stay with your majesty till death, but you must listen to our advice and come to terms with the Farengis, with the foreigners. And Chiotross is devastated by this. They won't run away with him. And that night he kind of wanders alone on the mountain, staring down at the British campfires. Now, Napier, meanwhile, is down with his senior officers thinking about what to do. deep down, I don't think they want to know the battle. His men are exhausted, they've gone a long way.
“你必须现在讲和。我们将与陛下同生共死，但你必须听从我们的建议，与法兰吉人，与外国人达成协议。”特奥德罗斯对此感到崩溃。他们不会和他一起逃跑。那天晚上，他独自在山上徘徊，盯着下面的英国营火。现在，纳皮尔与此同时正和他的高级军官们思考该做什么。在内心深处，我不认为他们想知道战斗。他的士兵们精疲力竭，他们走了很远的路。
They're hundreds of miles from a home. They have, of course, now got the hostages. They could just turn around and go back at this point. The reason they don't is it's the point that you made earlier on. The similarity with the fall of the Aztecs. They would have to go through lands controlled by rival warlords, and he knows those warlords expect him basically to finish Teodros off. So basically the deal is he has to finish Teodros off or else they risk being cut up as they march back to the coast.
他们离家有数百英里。他们当然现在已经有了人质。他们此时可以转身回去。他们没有这样做的原因是你在早些时候提出的观点。与阿兹特克帝国灭亡的相似之处。他们必须穿过由敌对军阀控制的土地，他知道那些军阀基本上期望他解决掉特奥德罗斯。所以基本上交易是他必须解决掉特奥德罗斯，否则他们冒着在撤回海岸时被切断的风险。
Exactly, right. Exactly. And I think finishing Teodros off might well involve taking him prisoner and bringing him back to London. And Teodros is probably frightened that he's going to be dragged through the streets and chains like a captured, you know, general and a Roman triumph, which probably would not have been the case. He would probably have had tea with Queen Victoria Osborne House and then been sort of encompassed. incarcerated in some country house in Hampshire. And worst case scenario, you're being exhibited at a freak show in the East End. No, that wouldn't.
完全正确。确实。我想解决掉特奥德罗斯很可能涉及俘虏他并把他带回伦敦。特奥德罗斯可能害怕他会被像一个被俘的将军一样拖在街上戴着镣铐，就像罗马凯旋式一样，这可能根本不会发生。他可能已经和维多利亚女王在奥斯本庄园喝过茶，然后被关押在汉普郡的某个乡村别墅里。最坏的情况是，你在东区的怪胎秀上被展览。不，那不会。
They wouldn't. Of course they wouldn't. Of course they wouldn't. Well, as we were discover in the bonus episode about what they do with Teodros's son, they send them to public schools. So, anyway, Monday morning. Teodros has been outside all night and he climbs back up to the fortress. And his men are huddled around their campfires and they watch him in silence. and Teodros says,
他们不会的。当然他们不会。当然他们不会。好吧，正如我们在关于他们如何对待特沃德罗斯儿子的加长版剧集中所发现的那样，他们把他们送到了公立学校。总之，周一早上。特沃德罗斯整晚都在外面，他爬回了堡垒。他的手下蜷缩在营火旁，沉默地看着他。特沃德罗斯说，
come on, death or glory. One last stand, let's attack the British. Bring your weapons and follow me. And he leads them out of the Citadel down this path. They get about halfway down the mountain and then a lot of them say, hold on, this is mad. I'm not attacking the British again. We would rather seek death in Magdalene, they say.
来吧，不成功便成仁。最后一搏，让我们攻击英国人。带上你们的武器跟我来。他带领他们走出城堡，沿着这条小路走下去。他们走到半山腰时，很多人说，等等，这太疯狂了。我不会再攻击英国人了。他们说，我们宁愿在马格达拉求死。
And a very deflated Teodros says, fine, we'll go back. So they trudge back up again. God, it's up and down, isn't it? all this story is. I know. Constant. He's getting his steps in, that's for sure. A lot of his men slip away.
一个非常沮丧的特沃德罗斯说，好吧，我们回去。于是他们又艰难地爬了回去。天哪，这故事真是起起落落，不是吗？我知道。没完没了。他肯定是在做运动。他的很多手下都溜走了。
Yeah, they know this is all over. So by the afternoon of Easter Monday, he's in Magdalore with a dwindling band of loyalists, and they're sort of stacking boulders against the outer gate. Meanwhile, Napier has ordered his guns to start shelling the Abyssinian Citadel, and the shells are getting closer and closer. By about four o'clock in the afternoon, the first British troops were advancing up the park,
是的，他们知道一切都结束了。所以到了复活节周一的下午，他带着一小群忠诚的追随者留在马格达拉，他们正把巨石堆在外面大门边。与此同时，内皮尔下令他的火炮开始轰炸阿比西尼亚城堡，炮弹越来越近。到了下午四点左右，第一批英军正沿着小路推进，
towards the sort of outer gates. And the shells are now landing inside the walls between the inner and outer gates. So Teotros and his remaining loyalists begin to fall back towards the inner gate. At this point, the British have brought scaling ladders with them, and they start to scale the ladders and to climb the outer ramparts. Some of them get to the outer gate and they start to force open the doors with kind of crowbars and stuff. Now, Teodros and his companions are kind of firing at them from the inner gateway, but it's completely pointless.
朝着外面的大门走去。炮弹现在正落在内外大门之间的墙内。于是特沃德罗斯和剩下的忠诚者开始向内门撤退。此时，英国人已经带来了云梯，他们开始攀爬云梯，爬上外面的城墙。有些人到达了外门，开始用撬棍之类的东西强行打开大门。现在，特沃德罗斯和他的同伴们正从内门向他们开火，但这完全是徒劳的。
There are now hundreds of British soldiers streaming up the path and towards the outer gateway. And it's at this point that Teotra shouts his last order to his men. He shouts, flee, I release you from your allegiance, but I shall never fall into the hands of an enemy. And he pulls out a gun, and he puts the end in his mouth, and he pulls the trigger, and bang. That's it.
现在有数百名英国士兵沿着小路涌向外门。就在这时，特沃德罗斯向他的手下喊出了最后一道命令。他喊道，逃吧，我解除你们的效忠，但我绝不会落入敌人手中。他掏出一把枪，把枪口放进嘴里，扣动了扳机，砰的一声。就这样结束了。
He falls to the ground. And within moments his men have melted away, the gates have opened and the British troops are pouring in, and they see his body lying on the ground in the dust. And he is, of course, quite dead. And by his side lies the gun, with which he took his own life. And they pick it up and they see it is the silver dueling pistol that he was given as a gift from Queen Victoria. The one you told us to remember, exactly. He's killed himself with his present from Queen Victoria. You are like Agha Christi
他倒在地上。片刻之内，他的手下就四散而去，大门打开，英军蜂拥而入，他们看到他的尸体躺在尘土飞扬的地上。当然，他已经死透了。在他身边躺着那把枪，他用它结束了自己的生命。他们捡起枪，发现那是维多利亚女王送给他的银质决斗手枪。就是你让我们记住的那把，没错。他用维多利亚女王送给他的礼物自杀了。你就像阿加莎·克里斯蒂，
putting the candlestick on the mantelpiece in chapter two. That Chekhov's gun. I introduced the gun in Act 1 and it's going to recur in Act 5. Yes. So that is the end of Teodros, the Emperor of Abyssinia. Dr. Blanc, who had been his hostage, did the post-mortem. And Dr. Blanc said later,
在第二章把烛台放在壁炉架上。那是契诃夫之枪。我在第一幕介绍了这把枪，它会在第五幕再次出现。是的。这就是阿比西尼亚皇帝特沃德罗斯的结局。曾是他的人质的布兰克医生进行了尸检。布兰克医生后来写道，
death that gave an air of calm grandeur to the features of one whose career had been so remarkable, whose cruelties are almost unparalleled in history. I mean, I think that's unfair, actually. But who at the last hour thought like a brave man and killed himself rather than surrender? And it was actually Mr. Rassam, who organized the funeral, which was held in the Coptic church on the Magdala Hilltop the next day. Tiodras would have, he would have loved that. He would have loved that. That's what he wanted. I mean, he died, as he would have wanted in some ways. And he got the funeral he would have wanted, devised by his beloved.
死亡给那张面孔增添了一种平静的庄严，尽管他的一生如此非凡，尽管他的残暴在历史上几乎是无与伦比的。我的意思是，我觉得这其实不公平。但在最后一刻，他像个勇敢的人一样思考，宁愿自杀也不愿投降？实际上是拉萨姆先生组织了葬礼，第二天在马格达拉山顶的科普特教堂举行。特沃德罗斯会喜欢的，他会喜欢的。这就是他想要的。我的意思是，他在某种程度上死得如他所愿。他得到了他想要的葬礼，由他所爱的人策划。
The only thing he'd have liked, I think he'd have liked Queen Victoria to have been there. I think, no, I think it's all about Rastan. Yeah, maybe. Don't forget, he'd been very rude about Queen Victoria being a woman. He had, yes, he had. So at the end, the other defenders surrendered almost immediately, and this was the cue for the British to start piling into the manuscripts, the relics and the treasures.
唯一的一点，我想他会希望维多利亚女王也在场。我想，不，我觉得这都是关于拉萨姆的。是的，也许吧。别忘了，他曾对维多利亚女王身为女性发表过非常粗鲁的言论。是的，他确实说过。所以最后，其他守军几乎立即投降了，这成了英国人开始抢掠手稿、文物和财宝的信号。
Now, as we said, this is not an entirely straightforward British bad guys, plundering stuff story because of course this was stuff that Teodros had basically accumulated in his campaigns and he had an absolutely mad collection. So he had religious relics and vestments and crowns and goblets. He had a lot of manuscripts. He had musical instruments. He had weirdly a collection of Staffordshire pottery. He had umbrellas. He had cases of wine. He had carpets. He had lion skins. had toy soldiers and a collection of cameras, all of which ended up in the baggage of all these British soldiers. There was a massive looting free-for-all, which only ended when Napier himself arrived, came up the path. And he came up with a military band playing God Save the Queen
现在，正如我们所说，这并不是一个完全简单的英国坏人掠夺东西的故事，因为这些东西当然是特沃德罗斯在征战中积累起来的，他有一个绝对疯狂的收藏。他有宗教文物、法衣、王冠和高脚杯。他有很多手稿。他有乐器。奇怪的是，他还有一套斯塔福德郡陶器。他有雨伞。他有几箱葡萄酒。他有地毯。他有狮子皮。他有玩具士兵和一堆照相机，所有这些最终都进了这些英国士兵的行李里。这是一场大规模的抢劫狂欢，直到内皮尔本人沿着小路走上来才结束。他带着一支军乐队，演奏着《天佑女王》
and see the conquering hero comes. And Napier said, now, come on, we're British. We don't want a massive free-for-all. We will distribute the booty properly. And basically, they doled out all the cash to all the troops. And then a few days later, he held a gigantic auction where all the sort of relics and stuff and the Cameras and the Staffordshire pottery was auctioned off to the highest bidders. So we can talk possibly in our bonus about some of the loot. Well, the notorious one is the tabots, isn't it? Yes. They're not books exactly. They're kind of tablets, aren't they?
和《征服英雄归来》。内皮尔说，好了，我们是英国人。我们不想要大规模的抢劫狂欢。我们将妥善分配战利品。基本上，他们把所有的现金分给了所有部队。几天后，他举行了一场大型拍卖会，所有文物、照相机和斯塔福德郡陶器都被拍卖给了出价最高的人。所以我们可能可以在我们的加长版中谈谈其中的一些战利品。嗯，最臭名昭著的是塔博特石板，对吧？是的。它们不是严格意义上的书。它们更像是石板，对吧？
Helped by the British Museum, I think, aren't they? And there's one held by Westminster Abbey, I think. So we talk about some of the loot in our special bonus episode on this for Restis History Club members. We also talk about what happened to some of the hostages like Hummus, Rassam. And we talk about two other characters that we haven't really mentioned. So one is a guy called Captain Speedy, who was one of Napier's deputies, literally Speedy. It's not his nickname. That was his name, Captain Speedy.
在大英博物馆的帮助下，我想是这样，对吧？我想威斯敏斯特教堂也收藏了一块。所以我们会在为“历史俱乐部”成员准备的特别加长版剧集中讨论其中的一些战利品。我们还会讨论像胡姆斯·拉萨姆这样的人质发生了什么。我们还会谈论我们之前没有真正提到的另外两个角色。一个是叫斯皮迪上尉的人，他是内皮尔的副手之一，真的是“斯皮迪”（意为快速）。这不是他的绰号。那是他的名字，斯皮迪上尉。
But Captain Speedy before this had been Teodros's military advisor. So he had an extraordinary career. He knew all about the guns. He did. And the other person is Chodros' son, Prince Alamehahu. And he was sent back to England. He was introduced to Queen Victoria, and he ended up as a border at rugby, a Flashman's old school.
但在那之前，斯皮迪上尉曾是特沃德罗斯的军事顾问。所以他有着非凡的职业生涯。他非常了解枪支。他确实了解。另一个人是特沃德罗斯的儿子，阿拉马耶胡王子。他被送回了英国。他被介绍给了维多利亚女王，最终成了拉格比公学的寄宿生，那是弗莱什曼的母校。
So we'll talk about him and his extraordinary trajectory. But back to Napier. Now, we talked before about comparisons with other military expeditions, perhaps particularly those launched by our American cousins. And the difference with Napier is Napier has absolutely no interest in installing a client regime, in sorting, you know, making Abyssinia safe for democracy, any of that sort of stuff. His orders were to get in, get the hostages and get out again, and that is precisely what he's going to do. He's not interested in Abyssinia at all.
所以我们会谈谈他和他非凡的轨迹。但回到内皮尔。我们之前谈过与其他军事远征的比较，也许特别是我们美国表亲发起的那些。内皮尔的不同之处在于，他完全没有兴趣建立一个附庸政权，或者说，让阿比西尼亚变得对民主安全，或者任何类似的事情。他的命令是进入，救出人质，然后撤出，这正是他要做的。他根本对阿比西尼亚不感兴趣。
He sends a message to his army the day after the auction. He says, the Queen and the People of England entrusted to you, an very arduous and difficult expedition to release our countrymen from a long and painful captivity and to vindicate the honour of our country. We've done it. We're going home. The message that Jimmy Carter never got to deliver. Exactly right. So the result of this, actually, is that Abyssinia is left leaderless and the result is 20 years of chaos. Because basically, it's like they've gone in and they've kicked over an ant heap, isn't it? Yeah. Complete chaos. You sort yourselves out. I mean, the thing, what could they have done?
拍卖后的第二天，他给他的军队发了一条信息。他说，英国女王和人民委托你们进行了一次非常艰巨和困难的远征，以将我们的同胞从长期痛苦的囚禁中解救出来，并维护我们国家的荣誉。我们做到了。我们要回家了。这是吉米·卡特从未能传达的信息。完全正确。所以，这实际上导致的结果是阿比西尼亚陷入了无政府状态，结果是20年的混乱。因为基本上，这就像他们进去踢翻了一个蚁丘，不是吗？是的。完全混乱。你们自己解决吧。我的意思是，他们还能做什么？
They could have chosen a client king. It would probably have all ended in disaster, frankly. I think they absolutely did the right thing in getting out. There's 20 years of civil war. There's then the war in the Sudan which spills over. The Mardi, our old friend General Gordon. And it only ends really at the end of the century under a guy called Menelik II. And he really establishes himself as a kind of Abyssinian hero by beating the Italians at the Battle of Adwar in 1896,
他们本可以选择一个附庸国王。坦率地说，那可能最终都会以灾难告终。我认为他们撤出的决定绝对是正确的。随后发生了20年的内战。然后是苏丹战争，战火蔓延开来。马赫迪，我们的老朋友戈登将军。直到世纪末，在一个叫孟尼利克二世的人领导下，这一切才真正结束。他在1896年的阿杜瓦战役中击败了意大利人，真正确立了自己作为阿比西尼亚英雄的地位，
which is seen as a kind of landmark moment. humiliation of a European army by an African one. But all that lies in the future. So Napier and Co march back to the coast, their bands playing, their flags flying. They get there in June. Everything is loaded back onto the ships. The railway tracks, the telegraph wires,
这被视为一个里程碑式的时刻。非洲军队羞辱了欧洲军队。但这一切都在未来。所以内皮尔和他的同僚们吹着军号、打着旗帜向海岸进发。他们在六月到达那里。一切都被装回船上。铁路轨道、电报线、
the elephants. The elephants are all right, are they? The elephants are all right. The hostages. Eight days later, Napier embarks for Suez. He goes back to England. In England he is a hero. We rejoice that the honour of the British flag and the dignity of the British name have been vindicated.
大象。大象没事吧？大象没事。人质们。八天后，内皮尔启程前往苏伊士。他回到了英国。在英国，他是个英雄。我们欢呼，因为英国国旗的荣誉和英国名字的尊严得到了维护。
Asiatics will ponder and talk over the fate of a man who imprisoned British subjects, and they'll think twice about challenging the power that triumphed over the black king. So quite pungent stuff from British editorials. Napier is given the thanks of Parliament. He's given a reception by the Queen, he's promoted to Field Marshal, and he is given a hereditary peerage. So he becomes Baron Napier of Magdala, and there's still a Baron Napier of Magdala today.
亚洲人会思考并谈论那个囚禁英国臣民的人的命运，他们会三思而后行，不敢挑战那个战胜了黑人国王的强权。所以英国社论的措辞相当尖锐。内皮尔获得了议会的感谢。他受到了女王的接见，被晋升为陆军元帅，并被授予世袭贵族爵位。所以他成为了马格达拉的内皮尔男爵，今天仍然有马格达拉的内皮尔男爵。
And when he dies in 1890, he's a national hero, and there's a statue put up in Kensington. A Queensgate, you can still see it today. But talk of statues, we should end in Abyssinia. So Teodros in Abyssinia, or rather Ethiopia, as we now call it, is a cult figure today. So in his brilliant book on this, Philip Marsden talks about going to the markets in Addis Ababa and seeing Teodros T-shirts and badges,
当他在1890年去世时，他是一位民族英雄，肯辛顿竖立了一座雕像。在女王之门，你今天仍然可以看到它。但说到雕像，我们应该以阿比西尼亚作为结束。所以特沃德罗斯在阿比西尼亚，或者我们现在称之为埃塞俄比亚的地方，今天是一个偶像人物。所以菲利普·马斯登在他关于此事的精彩著作中谈到去亚的斯亚贝巴的市场，看到特沃德罗斯的T恤和徽章，
seeing his image stenciled on the walls of bars. He's now seen as a patriotic hero who died fighting European imperialism, a kind of symbol of Ethiopian independence. And the most obvious reminder of him, you can go to Emperor Teodros Square, which is in the centre of Addis Ababa. and basically this is a giant roundabout and unbelievably this roundabout is situated on of all things Churchill Avenue.
看到他的形象被喷绘在酒吧的墙上。他现在被视为一个死于反抗欧洲帝国主义的爱国英雄，是埃塞俄比亚独立的象征。关于他最明显的提醒，你可以去亚的斯亚贝巴市中心的特沃德罗斯皇帝广场。基本上这是一个巨大的环岛，令人难以置信的是，这个环岛竟然坐落在丘吉尔大道上。
Who was at the Battle of Omdaman? Who was at the Battle of Omdaman, exactly. It was no stranger to a sort of Horn of Africa battle. Now, there is no statue to Orros, but you will be pleased to hear that in the middle of this roundabout there is a replica of his beloved giant gun. Sebastopol.
谁参加了恩图曼战役？谁参加了恩图曼战役，没错。他对非洲之角的战斗并不陌生。现在，那里没有特沃德罗斯的雕像，但你会很高兴听到，在这个环岛中间有一个他心爱的巨炮“塞瓦斯托波尔”的复制品。
Oh, fabulous. So you could go and see this. If we haven't done the rest of history trip to Addis Ababa, we'd obviously go to the... But what about the actual gun?
哦，太棒了。所以你可以去看看这个。如果我们还没有进行“历史之旅”去亚的斯亚贝巴，我们显然会去……但那门真正的炮呢？
Well, this here is the thing. The real Sebastopol still exists. 250 miles away from Adis Ababa. It's half buried on the barren mountain top of what was once the fortress of Magdala.
嗯，这就是重点。真正的“塞瓦斯托波尔”仍然存在。距离亚的斯亚贝巴250英里。它半埋在曾经是马格达拉堡垒的荒凉山顶上。
There's nothing there now. And it was never fired. No one ever... worked out if it worked? It shows no sign of ever having been fired. Oh, God. So there it sits, this forgotten relic of this bizarre episode in British and indeed African history. And the mad thing about the whole business, as Sir Harry Flashman rightly puts it in his memoir, it could all have been avoided if only Queen Victoria had answered her letters. Well, on the subject of queens behaving badly and disastrous consequences ensuing.
那里现在什么都没有。而且它从未被发射过。没有人……弄清楚它是否能用？它没有任何曾经被发射过的迹象。天哪。所以它就那样坐落在那儿，作为英国乃至非洲历史上这一离奇插曲的被遗忘的遗迹。而整件事最疯狂的地方在于，正如哈里·弗莱什曼爵士在他的回忆录中正确指出的那样，如果维多利亚女王回复了她的信件，这一切本可以避免。好吧，说到女王行为不端并导致灾难性后果的话题，
Next week, we are back with the French Revolution and specifically with the terror. So the most dramatic, the most celebrated episode in the whole of the French Revolution, this is tumbrials, guillotines, blood flowing in the streets, the deaths of Marianne Toulinette, d'anton, Rob's Pierre, just... incredible drama and a completely blood-soaked climax. And that, if you are a member of The Rest Is History Club, you will be getting all six episodes this coming Monday. And if you're not, and you would like to hear the slicing of the guillotine for six solid episodes, you can go to the rest is history.com. So huge excitement for that.
下周，我们将回到法国大革命，特别是恐怖统治时期。所以这是整个法国大革命中最具戏剧性、最著名的插曲，这是囚车、断头台、街头流淌的鲜血，玛丽·安托瓦内特、丹东、罗伯斯庇尔的死亡，简直……令人难以置信的戏剧性，以及一个完全血腥的高潮。如果你是“历史俱乐部”的成员，你将在下周一收到全部六集。如果你不是，并且你想连续六集听到断头台落下的声音，你可以去therestishistory.com。所以对此非常期待。
But I think, Dominic, before we go, massive thanks for telling this forgotten button. incredibly dramatic story, simultaneously tragic and darkly comic, as is so often the case with British imperial history. Poor old, do you feel sorry if it's your dross? I really liked him. You wouldn't like him if he'd shackled your... No, I wouldn't have wanted to be a hostage. But I tell you what I liked about him.
但我认为，多米尼克，在我们结束之前，非常感谢你讲述这个被遗忘的、令人难以置信的戏剧性故事，它既悲剧又带有黑色幽默，正如英国帝国历史中经常出现的那样。可怜的老家伙，你为特沃德罗斯感到难过吗？我真的很喜欢他。如果他把你锁起来，你就不会喜欢他了……不，我不想成为人质。但我告诉你我喜欢他什么。
I liked his style as a letter writer. Yeah. I would have loved to get a letter from him. And unlike Queen Victoria, I would have replied him to become his pen pal. Maybe rest of history listeners, if those people, you'd be a letter. people who, you know, feel fondly disposed to Tom, why don't you send in your letters to him in the style of Teodros II? And there'll be a prize for the, the prize is, Tom will take you, just the two of you on a trip to Sebastopol to inspect the mortar in the middle of nowhere
我喜欢他作为写信人的风格。是的。我很乐意收到他的信。而且不像维多利亚女王，我会回复他，成为他的笔友。也许“历史”节目的听众，那些对汤姆有好感的人，为什么不以特沃德罗斯二世的风格给他写信呢？会有奖品，奖品是，汤姆会带你，就你们两个，去一趟塞瓦斯托波尔，去检查那个位于荒郊野外的迫击炮，
in Ethiopia. What could possibly go wrong? Take some dueling pistols with us as well. It'd be great. Anyway, Dominic, thank you. That was great. Thank you for listening. Bye-bye. Bye-bye. where some see heroes and others see egos Bloomberg sees the era of billionaire athletes while others follow the noise we follow the money learn more at Bloomberg.com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在埃塞俄比亚。还能出什么差错呢？带上一些决斗手枪一起去。那会很棒。总之，多米尼克，谢谢你。那太棒了。感谢您的收听。再见。再见。在有些人看到英雄而另一些人看到自我的时候，彭博社看到了亿万富翁运动员的时代，而当其他人追随噪音时，我们追随金钱。在Bloomberg.com了解更多。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。